cette sénateurs qui sont parvenus à un
accord chargent maintenant aux deux
chambres d'entérinées elles se cet
accord par un vote premier à ouvrir le
bal le Sénat c'est à vivre dans quelques
minutes pour l'occasion publique c'est
réinstaller en salle des conférences
pour suivre tous ces débats en cette
salle et conférence qui joue que cette
émission on va donc pouvoir suivre ces
échanges au plus près on va aussi être
avec notre journaliste Mathias sarez en
tribune de presse bonjour Mathias quelle
est ma compagnie toute la matinée on a
pris l'habitude d'industrer grand direct
avec ses 10 jours de réforme des
retraites alors Mathias comment est-ce
que ça va se passer cette matinée et
bien écoutez Quentin ça va se passer
sous la forme d'une sorte de discussion
générale il y a donc d'abord les deux
rapporteurs pour le Sénat de la
commission mixte paritaire qui vont
prendre la parole une séquence qui
devrait durer 5 minutes il s'agit
d'Elisabeth Doisneau et René Paul Savary
viennent d'ailleurs d'arriver dans
l'hémicycle ensuite le gouvernement
prendra la parole le ministre du Travail
Olivier du soft mais également Gabriel
Atta le ministre des contes publics sans
limite de temps pour les membres du
gouvernement et puis nous passerons aux
explications de vote 9 orateurs prévus
tous chefs de fil de leur groupe sur la
question des retraites il est donc des
prises de parole de Catherine de roche
de Raymond ponce Xavier yaccovelli
Monique Lubin ou encore katie a poursu
poli alors les prises de parole pour les
groupes sont limités à 5 minutes il aura
également une prise de parole pour les
non inscrits c'est Stéphane Ravier qui
expliquera donc son vote pendant 3
minutes voilà donc une séquence qui
devrait durer entre 1h et 1h30 il y aura
également deux possibilités que les
débats se rallongent un que le
gouvernement décide de déposer de
nouveaux amendements sur le texte c'est
le seul qui a cette possibilité là ou
encore que les oppositions décident de
déposer des motions de procédure il n'en
reste qu'une possible à déposer ce matin
il s'agirait d'une émotion de rejet
alors la gauche devrait semblablement
écarter cette possibilité qu'en tant
pour concentrer sur des recours au
Conseil constitutionnel merci Mathias
pour tous ces explications on a
effectivement un amendement du
Gouvernement qui serait déposé c'est un
amendement technique on suivra ça dans
les débats alors quels sont les
dispositions importantes qui ont été
adoptées par la commission mixte
paritaire il y en a beaucoup qui
viennent du Sénat il faut dire aussi que
le texte a été examiné jusqu'au 20e
article au Sénat alors que les députés
se sont arrêtés à l'article 2 d'abord il
y a la surcotte jusqu'à 5% pour les
maires de famille qui ont une carrière
complète à 63 ans et qui continuerait à
travailler jusqu'à 64 ans à noter que en
ce qui concerne les maires de famille
deux amendements portés par la gauche
sénatoriale ont été conservées le
garantie sommaire de bénéficier de
certains trimestres liés à l'éducation
de leur enfant pas de quoi convaincre
pour autant la gauche sénatorial écouter
hier Monique Lubin chef de fil des
socialistes au micro de Jonathan du
priez et quand on est arrivé ce matin
tout était
fait mais il faut surtout pas
faire croire aux gens qu'il y avait
encore des marges de manœuvre en CMP
aujourd'hui tout était réglé voilà c'est
un arrangement entre la droite et la
droite quoi on fait voilà la droite
macroniste démontre qu'elle est de
droite au cas où on n'aurait pas encore
compris et la droite des républicains
s'accorde parfaitement avec la droite
macroniste et tout ça ça fait un projet
de droite voilà alors que dans
l'hémicycle le président du Sénat Gérard
Larcher est en train de s'installer
public c'est l'un qui bouleverse son
antenne pour vous faire suivre et bien
c'est débats autour de la lecture des
conclusions de la commission mix
paritaire la séance vient d'être ouverte
on va tout de suite se diriger dans
l'émission
le compte-rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribuée
nous n'avons pas reçu d'observation le
procès-verbal est donc adopté sur les
réserves d'usage
je ne vois pas d'observation séance
l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen des
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire chargée de proposer un texte
commun sur le projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023 je vais immédiatement
donner la parole à Madame elisabethouano
rapporteur pour le Sénat de la
commission mixte paritaire
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres monsieur le rapporteur madame
la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales chers collègues la
commission mixte paritaire réunit hier
pour examiner les dispositions restants
en discussion de ce projet de loi de
financement rectificative de la sécurité
sociale 2023 a réussi à établir un texte
commun
lors de ces travaux René Paul Savary et
moi-même avons veillé à rester fidèle à
l'esprit de la majorité sénatoriale
cette réforme dont nous savons demandera
des efforts aux Français doit atteindre
pleinement son but ramener notre système
de retraite à l'équilibre à l'horizon de
2030 afin de garantir sa soutenabilité
financière au bénéfice des générations
futures
c'est en ayant cet objectif en tête que
tout en s'inscrivant tout en inscrivant
ces marqueurs dans le texte le Sénat a
veillé en première lecture à rester dans
une épure financière proche de
l'équilibre
René Paul Savary vous détaillera
certains choix de la CMP qui se
traduiront par des coûts supplémentaires
pour le système de retraite par rapport
à la version du texte adopté par le
Sénat
néanmoins messieurs les ministres
j'espère que vous serez en mesure de
nous confirmer que le texte issu de la
commission mixte paritaire permet le
retour à l'équilibre des comptes en 2030
moyennant peut-être un nouvel ajustement
des taux de cotisation patronales
vieillesse et ATMP
en toute état de cause mes chers
collègues vous retrouverez dans le texte
qui vous est présenté les principales
mesures que nous avons examinées
et adopter tout au long de la semaine
dernière et même pour certaines depuis
plusieurs années dans le cadre des PLFSS
je pense naturellement au décalage
progressif de l'âge d'ouverture des
droits à la retraite de 62 à 64 ans
ainsi qu'à l'accélération de la réforme
Touraine sur lesquelles reposent
l'équilibre financier de ce PLFR SS je
pense aussi à la mise en extinction
extinction des principaux régimes
spéciaux avec la clause dite du
grand-père au terme de laquelle les
personnes embauchées à compter du
premier septembre 2023 dans les
entreprises et institutions concernées
seront affiliés au régime général pour
le risque vieillesse
je pense également à l'abandon du projet
de transfert aux URSSAF de l'activité de
recouvrement de l'agircargo et de la
Caisse des dépôts et consignations qui a
été confirmé par la CMP enfin je vous
précise que la CMP a confirmé
l'introduction dans l'annexea du
principe de compensation intégrale par
l'État dès 2023 des surcos engendrés par
la hausse de cotisation patronale cnrcl
pour les employeurs publics concernés
du fait du maintien de ses nombreux
marqueurs du Sénat et avec les autres
dispositions qui vont vous être
présentés par René Paul Savary je vous
appelle mes chers collègues à approuvé
les conclusions de la commission mix
paritaire et je vous remercie de votre
attention merci madame le rapporteur
général
et donner la parole à notre collègue
René Paul Savary rapporteur pour le
Sénat de la commission mixte paritaire
tin ce président très rapidement en
quelques minutes pour vous rapporter
cette commission mix paritaire
particulier compte tenu que l'Assemblée
nationale a été empêché de débattre et
de voter il appartenait justement de
recréer le débat au sein de cette
commission mix paritaire 9 heures 9
heures dans lequel il y a eu des
avancées un compromis trouvé entre les
exigences du Sénat à travers des mesures
auxquelles nous étions particulièrement
attachés en ce qui concerne par exemple
les maires de famille en ce qui concerne
l'usure professionnelle cette pâte du
Sénat était importante merci Monsieur le
Ministre également d'avoir accordé pour
l'employabilité des seniors d'avoir
accordé le fait de créer une un accord
national interprofessionnel sur l'emploi
des seniors demandeurs d'emploi de
longue durée c'est important c'est comme
ça que nous pourrons réussir il
appartenait également de prendre en
compte des avancées de la et des
propositions de l'Assemblée nationale
qui n'avaient plus être débattu jusqu'au
bout et notamment ce qui concerne les
carrières longues pour lesquelles il y a
une avancée significative avec les 25
ans les 43 annuités minimum pour les
bornes d'âge et qui permettront à
certains véritablement d'être pris en
compte dans la durée de cotisation c'est
une avancée importante et si le fruit de
cette réflexion qui a fait en sorte que
nous puissions je pense voter sans état
d'âme cette réforme qui a été
particulièrement adoucie par rapport aux
mesures proposées directement par le
gouvernement et qui fait que nous avons
pris en compte les difficultés notamment
exprimées à travers l'usure
professionnelle nous y sommes attachés
et c'est la raison pour laquelle les
mesures du Sénat ayant été
en grande partie reprise dans le texte
final je vous invite mes chers collègues
à voter cette réforme merci monsieur le
rapporteur bien entendu les deux
orateurs pour la commission ils avaient
Doisneau et René Paul Sabri c'est
maintenant autour du gouvernement de
prendre la parole les ministres qui
n'ont pas de limite de temps de parole
dans cette lecture de la commission
mixte paritaire donc on va pouvoir
écouter tout d'abord le ministre du
Travail Olivier du soft merci monsieur
le président madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
la rapporteur général madame monsieur le
rapporteur madame le rapporteur pour
avis un accord mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs un accord a donc été trouvé un
accord entre les deux assemblées qui ont
su se retrouver sur l'essentiel autour
de cette réforme des retraites un accord
qui réaffirme sans ambiguïté
l'attachement de la représentation de la
représentation nationale à notre système
par répartition
hérité de la prière un accord enfin qui
permet de mettre aux voix un texte
profondément enrichi après plusieurs
semaines débat parlementaire le texte
qui est soumis au vote de vos deux
assemblées conjugue le cœur de la
réforme du président de la République le
quart de ses engagements avec de
nombreuses améliorations portées par les
parlementaires dans les deux chambres
ainsi les engagements pris au printemps
dernier devant les Français sont tenus
il s'agit travailler progressivement
plus pour équilibrer notre système de
retraite il s'agissait aussi de fermer
les principaux régimes spéciaux dans le
respect de la clause dite du grand-père
s'assurer aussi d'augmenter la retraite
minimale pour une carrière complète je
crois ainsi pouvoir dire que ce texte
est aussi pouvoir dire ce texte est
profondément enrichi jour après jour et
au fil de la discussion ainsi et grâce à
votre soutien nous avons concrétisé des
demandes de longue date par exemple pour
les sapeurs pompiers volontaires pour
les apprentis les stagiaires les
étudiants les sportifs font encore les
enseignants du primaire et je suis
certain que plusieurs améliorations
renforceront durablement la justice de
notre système de retraite sachant que
bien évidemment je n'ai pas été
exhaustif dans la liste que je viens de
faire
il est difficile quand on présente et
quand on commente les résultats d'une
commission mixte paritaire d'éviter
l'effet d'inventaire mais je suis
convaincu que chaque avancée compte et
mérite d'être reconnue en tant que tel
je pense notamment à la création d'une
surcote avant l'âge légal pour les mères
qui ont atteint la durée d'affiliation
requise avant c'est atteint de l'âge
d'ouverture des droits je pense à
l'instauration du CDI senior porter avec
force et convictions par votre
rapporteur prenez pas le Savary tout en
assurant le renvoie à leur site L1 du
Code du travail cher président du Sénat
je pense à la création d'une pension de
réversion pour les orphelins en
particulier selon situation de handicap
c'est un initiative du président
Retailleau je pense à la prise en compte
des parents confrontés au deuil d'un
enfant à l'initiative des groupes CRCE
RDP ou encore écologie je pense à la
perte des droits familiaux pour les
parents violents sur proposition de la
présidente billon je pense aura
forcément des droits à la retraite des
élus locaux porter ici notamment par les
rapporteur pour avis Sylvie vermillier
ou encore à la revalorisation des
pensions à Mayotte à l'initiative de
votre collègue tanning Mohamed suali
ainsi que du président Hervé Marseille
au total si je me livre à cette
inventaire c'est pour montrer que le
texte a été enrichi que le texte est
amélioré au fil des discussions et je
crois aussi qu'il peut montrer que ce
texte correspond à l'équilibre politique
qui résulte des travaux qui ont été les
vôtres
cet équilibre il doit être aussi
financier parce que demander un effort
financier et laisser filer les déficit
serait injuste et irresponsable et donc
nous maintiendrons l'équilibre du
système de retraite à l'horizon 2030 tel
que prévu par le texte initial c'est la
raison pour laquelle dans un premier
temps le gouvernement lève le gage pour
les gages restants l'article de bis A et
l'article 8 et c'est surtout la raison
pour laquelle nous prévoyons un
transfert supplémentaire de la branche
ATMP pour assurer financement tout en
laissant cette branche largement
excédentaire mais mon collègue Gabriel
Attal ministre délégué au compte public
il reviendra une fois que je dis cela
bien évidemment je ne lis pas les
désaccords qui persistent pas plus que
je note l'expression de l'opposition à
la réforme et je suis sûr à l'inverse
que personne ne contestera que le débat
a bien eu lieu
débat avec les partenaires sociaux après
quatre mois de concertation qui ont
permis de concrétiser des avancées que
personne n'aurait pu imaginer il y a
justement seulement quelques mois je
pense en particulier l'emploi des
seniors à la prévention de la pénibilité
alors que nous pensions les positions
des uns et des autres iraient
conciliables nous avons su je crois les
rapprocher des pas au Parlement aussi
bien évidemment avec 74 heures de
discussion à l'Assemblée nationale et
sans deux heures discussions au Sénat
nous pouvons dire que le débat a eu lieu
certains diront que c'est trop peu mais
il faut décrire la réalité telle qu'elle
est cette réforme a été davantage
discutée que les deux précédentes
réformes des retraites cumulées en
termes de temps d'expression et de temps
de débat d'autres aussi diront qu'il
reviendront sur cette réforme lorsqu'ils
arriveront un jour au pouvoir mais
qu'avons nous constater depuis 30 ans
avec autant de réforme de retraite
jamais je dis bien jamais une alternance
politique n'a remise en cause les
efforts demandés par les réformes
précédentes je crois pouvoir dire pour
conclure ce débat devant vous qu'au fond
nous avons suivi un seul fil rouge celui
du débat contradictoire et républicain
l'opposition moins ici qu'ailleurs
peut-être mais l'opposition à choisir
notre fil rouge c'est lui de
l'obstruction méthodique une obstruction
qui sacrifie la mission même d'un
parlementaire qui abîme le débat chaque
jour un peu plus et une obstruction qui
aura été assumée dans une confusion
Inuit entre la légitimité du Parlement
et l'expression de la rue de manœuvre en
blocage d'attaques personnelles en
comportement violent nous avons assisté
à une dérive moins ici qu'ailleurs mais
avec la même volonté d'une obstruction
que je trouve dangereuse je veux le dire
avec gravité devant vous la République
ne doit pas céder un pouce de terrain
c'est dérives et ne les combattrons jour
après jour mes textes s'apprêtent en
réalité beaucoup parmi les opposants ont
cité Victor Hugo tout en foulant parfois
aux pieds son sens aigu du
républicanisme qui aurait fait honneur
au débat
le gouvernement a fait un choix et
assume ce choix ce choix c'est celui de
surmonter cette obstruction pour assurer
la clarté et la sincérité des débats
d'abord en prévoyant qu'un amendement ou
un sous amendement n'ayant pas été
examiné par la commission des affaires
sociales ne puisse être présenté devant
le Parlement c'est l'application de
l'article 44 ligne 2 de la Constitution
ensuite en demandant au Sénat de se
prononcer par un vote unique sur
l'ensemble du texte après présentation
de l'ensemble des amendements par le
retard si l'article 44 alinéa 3 de notre
peine constitution certains auraient
voulu faire croire à une procédure
inhabituelle voire totalement inédite
mais répétez le même mensonge n'en fait
pas une vérité les choses sont simples
les trois précédentes réforme des
retraites ont eu recours au même vote
unique pour surmonter l'obstruction la
réforme dites Fillon l'examen en
première lecture au Sénat fait l'objet
d'un vote unique en juillet 2003 la
réforme dite verte un vote unique a été
appliqué en première lecture au Sénat en
octobre 2010 sur un quart des
amendements la réforme du Touraine enfin
un vote unique a été appliqué en
nouvelle lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
en novembre 2013
erreur réforme des retraites je ne
mentionnerai évidemment pas les nombreux
autres uniques qui ont eu lieu ici au
Sénat sur des projets de loi de finances
des projets de loi de financement
rectificatifs des projets de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale ou
encore des lois ordinaires comme la loi
de sécurisation de l'emploi au début de
l'année 2013 alors oui pour mettre fin à
la négation du parlementarisme et
garantir la clarté du débat le
gouvernement a bien recours alors
l'article à 44 aliné à 3 de la
Constitution et sur 9e jour de
ralentissement voir des blocages et des
bas avant que le texte puisse être mise
au vote dans sa totalité et adopter je
l'espère par votre assemblée je souhaite
vous dire que et j'espère avec vous que
nous pourrons ainsi achever cette
navette parlementaire c'est aussi
rappeler que cette réforme s'inscrit
dans un objectif plus large fixé par le
président de la République au cœur de la
feuille de route celui du plein emploi
il suppose de mobilier tous les de
mobiliser tous les leviers à notre
disposition pour y parvenir nous l'avons
fait il y a quelques mois avec
l'assurance chômage nous le faisons avec
les retraites nous allons faire surtout
avec le projet de loi pour le travail le
plein d'emploi qui viendra dans quelques
semaines devant vous autour de sujets
cruciaux comme la mise en place de
France travail le comté universel le
partage de la valeur la suite des
Assises du travail en matière de
conditions et de qualité de vie au
travail mais aussi de nombreux sujets
permettant à la fois d'aller vers le
plein emploi et de faire en sorte que ce
plein emploi soit aussi un bon emploi
merci pour votre travail merci pour
votre attention et je l'espère à bientôt
pour de nouveaux textes et de nouveaux
débats
voilà pour ce discours d'Olivier du soft
à l'occasion de la lecture des
conclusions de la Commission
mixparitaire on a aussi entendu la
rapporteur général ils avaient donné
s'adressait aux deux ministres en disant
j'espère que vous saurez nous convaincre
que le texte issu de la CMP permet le
retour à l'équilibre des comptes c'est
ça l'enjeu également et on va écouter
attentivement Gabriel Attal sur ce point
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
la rapporteur général monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
nous sommes face à un vote qui
conditionnera les 15 prochaines années
de la vie de notre pays et du quotidien
de nos concitoyens un vote pour une
génération dans le vote que vous vous
apprêtez à faire il y a l'avenir de
toute une génération celle qui travaille
et qui souhaitent garder son mode de vie
une fois arrivé au bout d'une vie de
labeur à la retraite dans le vote que
vous vous apprêtez à faire il y a aussi
tout ce qui fait notre pays son modèle
social sa vie politique et parlementaire
la cohérence des valeurs politiques
défendues par les représentants du
peuple sa capacité à aller de l'avant
mais aussi un choix profond entre le
travail et l'impôt
le vote que vous apprêtez à faire ne
vient pas seulement trancher un débat
politique et médiatique de plusieurs
mois il n'est pas simplement le point
final d'une séquence difficile qui je
suis parfaitement lucide à angoisser et
parfois diviser notre pays ce vote il
est aussi il est surtout la réponse à
des questions aussi fondamentales que
ces trois questions là que je pose
devant vous ce matin
voulons-nous oui ou non garantir à
bientôt 20 millions de retraités qui
pourront compter sereinement sur une
retraite financée afin de pouvoir
préserver leur mode de vie qu'ils n'ont
aucune envie de sacrifier pensons-nous
que c'est le travail qui entraîne la
prospérité d'une nation ou bien que
c'est l'impôt qui crée la richesse
les valeurs et le projet pour lesquelles
les Français ont élu leur représentants
au Parlement
doivent-ils être défendus par leur
parlementaire au risque sinon d'une
fissure encore plus profonde de la
confiance entre le peuple et ses élus
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
pourrai ma pesantir sur les réponses que
le gouvernement souhaite apporter à ces
questions je pourrais vous redire que
l'unique raison pour laquelle nous
faisons cette réforme c'est pour
préserver le patrimoine de ceux qui
n'ont que leur travail pour vivre et
pouvoir simplement leur dire sereinement
les yeux dans les yeux vos pensions ne
baisseront pas vos salaires ne
diminueront pas vos impôts
n'augmenteront pas
je pourrais vous dire aussi que la
réponse du gouvernement au choix entre
le travail et plus d'impôts et clair
c'est le travail qui crée la richesse
pas les impôts supplémentaires et que ce
choix nous guide nous oblige et que ce
choix du travail sur l'impôt c'est
certes le choix de l'effort mais c'est
surtout le choix de la prospérité et je
pourrais vous dire enfin que oui le
respect des engagements pris devant les
Français est au cœur du pacte entre le
peuple et ses représentants mais ce
n'est pas à vous ce n'est pas au Sénat
que j'ai besoin de le dire vous avez
toujours respecté vos engagements ce qui
se joue aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le
gouvernement qui en décide ce sont les
représentants du peuple par leur vote
votre vote c'est la démocratie cette
démocratie à la fois encadrée et
garantie par notre Constitution sans
laquelle rien n'est légitime
car notre Constitution c'est le cœur
même du pacte entre les Français et
leurs élus ce pacte qui existe depuis
que la France et les Français votent ce
pacte qui a permis des avancées majeures
pour les Français ce pacte qui a
conforté à plusieurs reprises la
démocratie lorsqu'elle va s'y est et que
ses institutions ne parvenaient plus à
œuvrer pour le pays voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire dès le début de mon
intervention comme marque de respect à
la fois pour le Parlement et pour le
Sénat je le disais mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs ma conviction c'est que
c'est le travail qui crée la prospérité
et que c'est donc par le travail que
nous devons financer les évolutions de
notre modèle social l'une des évolutions
majeures auxquelles notre pays est
soumis c'est sa démographie les faits
sont implacables notre pays vieillit
notre pays comptera plus de retraités
qu'il n'en a jamais compté notre modèle
social devra donc financer plus de
retraite que jamais en 2030 nous aurons
à payer chaque mois la retraite de 20
millions de retraités c'est un quasi
doublement en une génération il y avait
12 millions de pension de retraite à
payer chaque mois au début des années
2000 aucun pays ne pourrait tenir ce
choc sans rien faire et d'ailleurs
presque tous les pays autour de nous
réforme où ont réformé leur retraite et
nous notre choix c'est de le réformer
par le travail oui c'est un effort mais
non il ne sera pas porté par tous de la
même manière indifféremment 4 français
sur 10 partiront à la retraite avant
bien avant l'âge légal mais 10 Français
sur 10 pourront continuer à bénéficier
d'une retraite sans hausse d'impôts ni
baisse de pension l'autre choix qui a
émergé au cours de plus de 200 heures de
débats à l'Assemblée nationale et au
Sénat c'est celui de l'impôt des
cotisations l'impôt toujours l'impôt
tout le temps l'impôt pour tous taxer
taxer taxer voilà l'autre projet qui a
émergé ce projet-là nous l'avons
combattu par les idées et je remercie la
majorité sénatoriale d'avoir contribué à
le repousser non pas par idéologie je le
sais mais par bon sens
qui serait les premières victimes des
hausses d'impôts les Français qui
travaillent dur qui se lèvent le matin
qui font vivre leur famille et tourner
le pays
taxer les plus riches taxés les grands
groupes cela peut toujours être
séduisant mais l'impôt de trop ça
commence par taxer ceux qui sont en haut
et ça finit par frapper ceux qui sont en
bas voilà pourquoi avec la majorité
sénatoriale nous avons repoussé avec
détermination toute tentative d'impôts
ou dose de cotisation en plus voilà
pourquoi ce texte se fonde sur des
valeurs communes le travail comme
condition de la prospérité et la
retraite comme au raison bien mérité
d'une vie de travail voilà pourquoi je
le dis le texte qui vous est soumis
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
c'est aussi le vôtre cette réforme des
retraites c'est aussi celle du Sénat et
des sénateurs ce texte est aussi le dos
le vote parce que je l'ai dit il prend
ses racines dans des valeurs communes le
travail la préservation de notre modèle
social le refus de tout impôt
supplémentaire
ce texte est aussi le vôtre parce qu'en
première lecture vous l'avez voté et
vous l'avez adopté ce texte est aussi le
vôtre parce qu'il est le fruit d'un
compromis politique construit patiemment
au fil de l'élaboration de ce texte de
sa discussion et de son vote en
commission puis en séance publique et
maintenant au cours de la commission
mixte paritaire qui a eu lieu hier c'est
compromis ils permettent des avancées
importantes c'est compromis ont abouté
abouti à des avancées que les Français
devront aussi à cette majorité
sénatoriale je pense notamment et je le
souligne d'autant plus que je m'y étais
opposé monsieur le rapporteur à
l'expérimentation d'un CDI senior avec
un dispositif recentré sur les
demandeurs d'emploi de longue durée
expérimentées sur plusieurs années c'est
je le sais une idée à laquelle les
rapporteurs étaient particulièrement
attachés comme d'ailleurs la majorité
sénatoriale c'est dans le texte que nous
vous proposons de voter je pense aussi
au compromis trouvé sur le sujet des
carrières longues avec la reprise du
dispositif proposé par le groupe LR à
l'Assemblée nationale je précise
toutefois que nous avons eu des
discussions nourries pour affiner ce
dispositif enfin je veux dire un mot du
dispositif de surcotte pour les maires
de famille introduit par la commission
des affaires sociales du Sénat et qui a
bien sûr été intégré à l'accord trouvé
hier c'est un apport majeur du Sénat qui
permettra aux femmes de bénéficier d'une
pension revalorisée jusqu'à 5% au titre
des trimestres liés à la naissance d'un
enfant ou de leur éducation les derniers
ajustements actés hier durant la CMP
dans bien sûr faire l'objet d'une
traduction financière c'est la raison
pour laquelle le gouvernement a déposé
un amendement de chiffres à l'article 6
qui actualise l'annexe A du texte
c'est-à-dire la trajectoire financière
pluriannuelle des régimes de sécurité
sociale mais je réponds à Madame la
rapporteur général qui a posé la
question oui à l'issue de la CMP et à
travers un nouveau transfert de taux
entre la branche ATMP et la branche
vieillesse l'équilibre de notre système
de retraite en 2030 et garantie par le
travail du Parlement et par le compromis
qui a été trouvé hier en commission
mixte paritaire voilà Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs ce que je
voulais vous dire alors que vous vous
apprêtez à voter une réforme importante
pour l'avenir de notre pays et pour le
mode de vie des Français et de nos
retraités si je devais résumer en ce
moment en trois mots je dirais que nous
sommes à un rendez-vous celui de nos
institutions celui de notre modèle
social et celui de notre prospérité
celui de nos institutions car elle
garantissent que notre pays peut
continuer à avancer et bien nos
institutions c'est vous c'est le Sénat
c'est le Parlement tout le Parlement
rien que le Parlement nos institutions
c'est notre Constitution toute notre
Constitution rien que notre Constitution
celui de notre modèle social car là
aussi rappelons-nous que nous sommes les
lointains héritiers nous au gouvernement
vous sur ces banques des hommes et des
femmes politiques qui ont eu le génie et
la générosité d'inventer notre modèle
social et qu'on a être les héritiers
cela veut dire tout faire pour le
perpétuer permettre de durer dans le
temps celui de notre prospérité enfin
car le choix que nous faisons est clair
créer de la richesse par l'activité pas
par la fiscalité aller de l'avant par
davantage de travail pas par davantage
d'impôts nous sommes au rendez-vous de
nos institutions de notre modèle social
et de notre prospérité mais s'il est un
rendez-vous qui compte par dessus tout
un rendez-vous que nous devons pas
manquer c'est celui de nos compatriotes
les Français ceux qui travaillent et qui
veulent continuer à faire vivre leur
famille à faire tourner leur pays sans
outrance et sans blocage ce qui
travaille et qui veulent continuer à
penser à la retraite comme un temps bien
mérité de leur vie on récolte enfin
sereinement le fruit d'une vie de
travail ce rendez-vous celui des
promesses que nous avons faites aux
Français celui des engagements que nous
avons pris et que nous devons tenir ce
rendez-vous il est maintenant alors
votons ce texte pour continuer à aller
de l'avant je vous remercie
voilà vous suivez ce moment crucial pour
la réforme des retraites en direct sur
l'antenne de Public Sénat et on vient
d'entendre les deux ministres on ouvre
maintenant un nouveau chapitre dans la
lecture des conclusions de la commission
Miss paritaire puisqu'on passe aux
explications de vote environ 45 minutes
et 9 orateurs pour les groupes
politiques qui vont tous donner leur
sentiment leur vision politique de cet
accord en CMP à la tribune première
oratrice Catherine de roche elle a
président de la commission des affaires
sociales qui va s'exprimer pour les
républicains elle va pouvoir
effectivement donner comme cela et bien
la vie de son groupe sur l'accord trouvé
il y a en commission de Miss paritaire
on retourne dans l'hémicycle
merci monsieur le Président comme je
viens de l'indiquer dans mon
intervention il s'agit d'un amendement
qui modifie l'annexe obligatoire
présentant les prévisions de recettes
les objectifs de dépenses et le tableau
d'équilibre par branche des régimes
obligatoires de base pour les années à
venir c'est un amendement de
coordination qui permet de tenir compte
en conformité avec le principe de
sincérité des lois financières des
impacts financiers des amendements
adoptés au Sénat et des modifications
issues de la CMP
quelle est la vie de la commission
madame la rapporteur général
la commission de séparé une ligne
à titre personnel j'apporte un avis
favorable parce que c'est un principe de
sincérité et c'est la traduction des
accords qui ont été trouvés hier en CMP
et aussi des votes du Sénat donc
c'est un avis favorable bien
[Musique]
l'amendement va être distribué
voilà on le voit il y a un amendement
qui a été déposé donc on est en train de
l'examiner avant de passer aux
explications de vote sur l'ensemble des
conclusions de la commission mix
paritaire quelle est cet amendement du
Gouvernement c'est un amendement
technique comme on dit c'est à dire un
moment qui vient rééquilibrer et bien
les financements de la réforme après
notamment et bien l'adoption en
commission esparitaire de mesure de
diverses mesures et donc il faut
rééquilibrer le total de l'addition
puisque c'est un texte financier et donc
cet amendement il va être distribué dans
l'hémicycle et examiner et il viendra
comme cela et bien parachever l'accord
en commission mixparitaire on retourne
dans les débats
qu'est-ce qu'il faut
si vous nous rejoignez sur l'antenne de
Public Sénat
voilà si vous nous rejoignez sur
internet depuis que ça il est 9h30 le
Sénat qui débat des conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire cette députés
et sept sénateurs qui étaient réunis
hier à l'Assemblée nationale et qui
après 9 heures de débats ce sont mis
d'accord sur un même texte une même
réforme des retraites c'est conclusions
de la commission mix paritaire qui ont
donc été trouvés à huis clos hier par là
c'est 14 parlementaires elles doivent
maintenant être entérinées c'est-à-dire
il doit y avoir un vote final pour les
valider alors c'est le Sénat qui s'en
est emparés le premier c'est ce que vous
vivez depuis 9h sur notre antenne et que
s'est-il passé on a eu les deux orateurs
pour la commission Elisabeth Doisneau et
René Paul Savary et qui ont pris la
parole pour présenter l'accord trouvé en
commission Miss paritaire puis le
gouvernement s'est exprimé on a entendu
Olivier dussat qui s'est voilà et bien
féliciter des accords trouvés sur le au
fond de la réforme hier ensuite Gabriel
Attal qui a et bien garanti l'équilibre
des régimes et on voit que il y a
maintenant un amendement du Gouvernement
un amendement technique un amendement
sur les équilibres financiers de la
réforme après justement les derniers et
les ajustements en commission
d'expéritaires un amendement technique
qui vient d'être distribué qui permet
d'équilibrer la réforme c'est cet
amendement qui vient d'être ajouté au
débat les sénateurs et bien ce sont vus
remettre cet amendement car il le
réclamait et c'est ce qui donc
interrompre pour l'instant la séance il
y aura ensuite les explications de vote
avec les groupes politiques neuf
orateurs qui vont prendre la parole
ensuite pour donner leur avis politique
leur opinion sur ce texte on va les
rejoindre notre journaliste mathiasarès
qui se trouve en tribune de presse et
qui m'accompagne toute cette matinée
bonjour à vous Mathias ça nous rappelle
les dix jours d'examens de la réforme
des retraites ce direct ce matin
explique-nous ce qui se joue aujourd'hui
absolument Quentin est bien nous sommes
donc dans cette discussion générale des
conclusions de la CMP vous l'avez
rappelé les rapporteurs pour le Sénat à
la commission mixte paritaire ont
d'abord pris la parole Elisabeth
Doisneau et René Paul Saint-Lary qui ont
salué l'accord trouvé entre les
sénateurs et les députés on vient
également d'entendre les représentants
du gouvernement Olivier du soft et
Gabriel Attal parler de la teneur des
échanges qui ont eu lieu aussi bien à
l'Assemblée qu'au Sénas à Lyon la clarté
des échanges qu'il y a eu ici avec les
sénateurs un ministre du Travail Olivier
du soft qui a également dit que et bien
des débats ont eu lieu en longueur ici
il les a salués je vous propose de
l'écouter
débat au Parlement aussi bien évidemment
avec 74 heures de discussions à
l'Assemblée nationale et sans deux
heures discussion au Sénat nous pouvons
dire que le débat a eu lieu certains
diront trop peu mais il faut décrire la
réalité telle qu'elle est cette réforme
a été davantage discutée que les deux
précédentes réforme des retraites
cumulées en termes de temps d'expression
et de temps de débat d'autres aussi
diront qu'il reviendront sur cette
réforme lorsqu'ils arriveront un jour au
pouvoir mais qu'avons-nous constater
depuis 30 ans avec autant de réforme de
retraite jamais j'y bien jamais une
alternance politique n'a remise en cause
les efforts demandés par les réformes
précédentes
voilà les débats qui sont en train de
reprendre dans l'hémicycle Catherine de
roche vient de prendre la parole il y a
des rappels en règlement on va rejoindre
l'hémicycle en direct
oui merci monsieur le Président
simplement pour préciser c'est un moment
qui est long puisqu'il reprend
l'intégralité de l'annexe A mais en
réalité il y a une modification par
rapport au texte initial c'est un
nouveau transfert de recettes entre la
branche ATMP et la branche vieillesse
pour garantir l'équilibre de notre
système comme je l'ai annoncé dans mon
intervention de 700 millions d'euros de
700 millions d'euros ce qui garantit
l'équilibre de notre système de retraite
c'est la seule évolution notable merci
Madame Cohen
oui merci monsieur le Président c'est un
rappel au règlement au titre de
l'article 44 je remercie madame la
présidente des affaires sociales enfin
de réunir la commission des affaires
sociales parce que pendant tout l'examen
on a eu beau faire des rappels au
règlement nous n'avons pas eu ce
privilège donc il y a je crois que la
démocratie a été pas mal bafouée et
franchement cette page d'amendement sans
suspension de séance à l'origine et à
nous laisser gracieusement lire en nous
disant qu'il n'y avait pas de
modification je trouve quand même que là
si les droits des parlementaires ne sont
pas bafoués alors je ne sais plus
comment on peut appeler donc la quelques
minutes
grappiller grâce à la générosité de la
présidente on accepte mais franchement
je voulais faire ce rappel au règlement
en mon nom et au nom de mon groupe parce
que là mes chers collègues j'attire
votre attention sur la façon dont les
parlementaires et notamment de
l'opposition sont traitées et c'est une
remise en cause du parlementarisme
je vais suspendre pour permettre la
réunion de la commission pour une
dizaine de minutes
voilà première suspension de séance il
est 9h35 nous sommes en direction
interne depuis Xéna pourquoi y a-t-il
une suspension de séance et bien parce
que le gouvernement a déposé un
amendement visiblement qui a fait cette
page un amendement technique certes mais
un abonnement important qui vient
rééquilibrer en fait la réforme des
retraites après tout ce qui a été adopté
en commission mixte paritaire sauf que
et bien les sénateurs n'ont pas vu cet
amendement après avant son dépôt en
séance il demande donc une suspension
pour que la Commission de l'affaire
sociale puisse s'en débattre et la
majorité de la droite et du centrage
accepté cette suspension vous l'avez vu
sur notre antenne 10 minutes de
suspension ils vont se réunir dans la
salle de la commission d'affaires
sociales donnaient leur opinion et bien
sûr cette amendement technique mais on
le voit à une ambiance qui est toujours
aussi électrique comme depuis et bien
mardi et l'article 7 on voit que ça
laisse des traces on voit que la gauche
sénatoriale et bien se plaint de la
façon dont la minorité et traiter au
Parlement donc ça repart de plus belle
on va en parler avec Mathias sarez
Mathias juste avant cette suspension je
vous ai interrompu vous nous disiez que
le gouvernement a donc pris la parole ce
matin c'est bien ça oui absolument
c'était le protocole après les deux
rapporteurs pour le Sénat auprès de la
commission mixte paritaire et bien le
protocole veut que le gouvernement
prenne également la parole on a entendu
Olivier du soft qui a parlé de la teneur
des échanges ici au Sénat avec moins
d'invectives qu'à l'Assemblée nationale
qui a également dit que bien personne ne
pourrait nier que le débat avait eu lieu
que cette réforme avait été plus débattu
que les deux précédentes cumulées il y a
également eu le ministre des comptes
publics et Gabriel Attal qui s'est
exprimé sur la légitime la légitimité
pardon de ce texte je vous propose de
l'écouter
votre vote c'est la démocratie cette
démocratie à la fois encadrée et
garantie par notre Constitution sans
laquelle rien n'est légitime car notre
Constitution c'est le cœur même du pacte
entre les Français et leurs élus ce
pacte qui existe depuis que la France et
les Français votent ce pacte qui a
permis des avancées majeures pour les
Français ce pacte qui a conforté à
plusieurs reprises la démocratie
lorsqu'elle vaciller et que ces
institutions ne parvenaient plus à
œuvrer pour le pays voilà Gabriel Attal
qui a parlé d'une réforme engageante
pour la vie des Français pour au moins
les 15 prochaines années on pensait donc
ensuite qu'on allait passer aux
explications de vote sauf que le
gouvernement avait donc décidé de
déposer un amendement sur l'article 6
sur l'annexe de l'article 6 qui a donc
donné lieu au débat et puis un petit
moment de latence on a vu les huissiers
passés dans les rangs pour distribuer
cet amendement le président l'archet qui
a également rappelé qu'il était
consultable en ligne voilà donc il y a
eu un petit une petite période de
concrètement et d'incrédulité notamment
sur les bancs de la gauche avant que et
bien Elisabeth Doisneau demande donc une
suspension pour que la commission des
affaires sociales se réunisse le temps
d'examiner cet amendement Quentin merci
Mathias pour toutes ces explications
alors cela devait être une formealité au
Sénat cette lecture de la conclusions de
la commission mixte paritaire mais on le
voit comme on pouvait s'y attendre il y
a toujours des rebondissements dans
l'examen de la réforme des retraites
pourquoi parce que la gauche sénatoriale
a demandé une suspension de séance pour
examiner cet amendement de 7 pages cet
amendement qui vient corriger les effets
sur la réforme et sur le financement de
la réforme des retraites on va écouter
avant cela ce qu'a dit René Paul Savary
qui est l'un des rapporteurs au Sénat de
la commission Miss paritaire il a pu
présenter tout ce qui avait été adopté
en commission mix paritaire il a même
dit nous pouvons voter sans état d'âme
cette réforme en écoute leur apportant
de la branche hier on se retrouve juste
après
très rapidement quelques minutes pour
vous rapporter cette commission mix
paritaire particulière compte tenu que
l'Assemblée nationale a été empêché de
débattre et de voter il appartenait
justement de recréer le débat au sein de
cette commission mixte paritaire 9
heures 9 heures dans lequel il y a eu
des avancées un compromis trouvé entre
les exigences du Sénat à travers des
mesures auxquelles nous étions
particulièrement attachés en ce qui
concerne par exemple les maires de
famille en ce qui concerne l'usure
professionnelle cette pâte du Sénat
était importante merci Monsieur le
Ministre également d'avoir accordé pour
l'employabilité des seniors d'avoir
accordé le fait de créer une un accord
national interprofessionnel sur l'emploi
des seniors demandeurs d'emploi de
longue durée c'est important c'est comme
ça que nous pourrons réussir il
appartenait également de prendre en
compte des avancées de la et des
propositions de l'Assemblée nationale
qui n'avait plus être débattu jusqu'au
bout notamment en ce qui concerne les
carrières longues pour lesquelles il y a
une avancée significative avec les 25
ans les 43 annuités minimum pour les
bornes d'âge et qui permettront à
certains véritablement d'être pris en
compte dans la durée de cotisation c'est
une avancée importante et c'est le fruit
de cette réflexion qui a fait en sorte
que nous puissions je pense voter sans
état d'âme cette réforme qui a été
particulièrement adouci par rapport aux
mesures proposées directement par le
gouvernement et qui fait que nous avons
pris en compte les difficultés notamment
exprimées à travers l'usure
professionnelle nous y sommes attachés
et c'est la raison pour laquelle les
mesures du Sénat ayant été en grande
partie reprise dans le texte final je
vous invite mes chers collègues à voter
cette réforme
merci monsieur le rapporteur nous sommes
en direct sur l'antenne de publics
Sénart pour suivre cette lecture des
conclusions de la commission mix
paritaire il y a eu un petit
retournement de situation un petit
rebondissements un petit coup de théâtre
puisque et bien le gouvernement a déposé
un amendement technique mais il fait 7
pages il y a donc une suspension de la
séance pour en parler avec Rémi Cardon
bonjour vous êtes sénateur socialiste de
la Somme benjamin du Sénat vous l'avez
eu entre les mains vous cet amendement
oui il y a quelques instants mais on a
bien vu que le retournement de situation
il est simple parce que la droite c'est
naturel n'a pas respecté la règlement et
donc du coup finalement la présidente de
la Commission a décidé enfin j'ai bien
enfin parce que pendant 10 jours on n'a
pas eu l'occasion de réunir la
commission des affaires sociales enfin
on a une effectivement une réunion de la
commission à faire sociale pour échanger
autour de cet amendement que j'ai eu il
fait cette page en tout cas il ridicule
on me demande de voter ou de me
positionner sur ce sur cet amendement on
a même pas le temps de le lire on avait
vu sur le dérouleur qui aurait un
amendement technique on pouvait
s'attendre à ce qui est comme ça des
correctifs sur la réforme après ce qui
s'est passé en commission exporter non
oui bah après monsieur le ministre avait
un temps de parole il pouvait très bien
nous prévenir que il y avait un
amendement qu'elle est arrivé il me
semble qu'il avait quand même quelques
minutes monsieur dussott et Monsieur
Attal donc si vous voulez même autant de
temps qui voulaient exactement ils
étaient limités donc si vous voyez ils
pouvaient aussi parler du tableau il
pouvait ici aussi parler de de cet
amendement donc moi encore une fois et
puis on nous a accusé en plus dans leur
propose cerise sur le gâteau c'est on a
bafoué le le
parlementarisme non non mais là ce genre
de méthode c'est quand même un bon
exemple d'obstruction parlementaire
parce que je sais pas si vous vous
rendez compte mais si dans un conseil
municipal on ne donnait pas les
délibérations et on vous demande de
voter comment voulez-vous ça se passe
bien c'est pas anodin c'est réunions de
la commission des affaires sociales
parce que ça permet notamment au
gouvernement on l'a vu pendant les 10
jours de faire tomber des sous
amendements de de l'opposition et donc
c'est pour ça que vous le premier c'est
réunions de la commission là la majorité
de la moitié du centre réunit la
commission des affaires sociales pour
examiner cet amendement de cette page
c'est qu'elle vous donne des gages elle
souhaite être réapaiser à nouveau le
débat au Sénat oui puis de rendre ces
amendements plus explicites c'est un
amant je le rappelle c'est un amendement
technique et ça mérite quand même
explication explication pour comprendre
pourquoi il y a eu des modifications
dans le tableau et donc moi ce que je
comprends c'est le temps de parole de
des deux ministres on était quand même
très élevé et je comprends pourquoi ils
en ont pas parlé un mot sur ce qui se
joue depuis maintenant le vote de
l'article 7 on sent que et bien ça peut
s'embraser à tout moment entre la droite
et la gauche sénatoriale vous êtes
d'accord pour dire qu'il c'est encore
tendu l'atmosphère au sein de
l'hémicycle on a entendu Laurence Cohen
et qui était très véhémente très
contrariée de la façon dont ça se
passait encore aujourd'hui entre la
droite et la gauche sénatoriale bah
c'est désolé d'exister j'ai envie de
vous dire
j'ai envie de leur dire désolé d'exister
désolé qui est une opposition voilà
maintenant si on les dérange bah écoutez
on peut aussi les laisser tranquilles
parce qu'ils ont l'habitude de justement
s'organiser avec le gouvernement pour
faire ce genre de manip donc si vous
voulez moi voilà je suis assez déçu
aussi du content parce que j'ai entendu
des propos très graves aussi de d'autres
collègues je ne dirai pas sur ce plateau
parce que sincèrement apparemment il y
aurait des hommes à abattre dont
Monsieur chanterait et moi-même
excusez-moi c'est ce genre de proposer
dans l'hémicycle à l'extérieur de
lucycle mais si ça revient à mes
oreilles qui vous reproche bah d'être
d'être à mon avis trop
trop imposant dans les débats ou de
prendre la parole peut-être de prendre
la parole voilà peut-être le de débattre
de proposer un débat qui alors peut-être
que on est trop provocateur sur le ton
peut-être qu'on doit baisser d'un cran
je sais pas je sais pas donc vous le
dise c'est des choses qu'on avait jamais
vu auparavant des attaques abdominales
c'est ça entre la gauche et la droite ça
c'est des choses qui donc et bien sont
la résultante de ce débat très tendu
qu'on voit depuis une semaine vous êtes
d'accord donc il y aura un avant après
au
malheureusement on est il y a encore un
texte assez clivant sur l'immigration
qui va arriver après qui à mon avis va
aussi réchauffer cette cette atmosphère
merci Rémi Cardon et on va laisser
madame assassy prendre votre place
immédiatement à ce micro bonjour et bien
associer et merci à Rémi Cardon bonjour
madame SSI vous êtes la présidente du
groupe communiste ici au Sénat il y a
cette suspension de séances qui est en
cours c'est peut-être aussi une façon
pour la droite et le centre d'apaiser
les débats que la Commission soit réunie
et vous le saluer
il y a des choses incompréhensibles et
je pense que ma collègue Laurence Cohen
a eu raison de faire ce rappel au
règlement c'est à dire que visiblement
cet amendement est arrivé tardivement il
est assez long il aurait mérité
effectivement que la page exactement il
aurait mérité quand même que la
commission des affaires sociales puisse
se pencher sur son son contenu je
rappelle quand même que pendant les
travaux sur ce texte la commission de
ces affaires sociales ne s'est
pratiquement pas réunis on nous fait des
discours sur l'anti parlementarisme
voilà je pense que là le gouvernement la
commission des affaires sociales et la
majorité sénatoriale joue le même jeu à
savoir de passer outre le travail
parlementaire est particulièrement la
parole de l'opposition dans dans nos
travaux on est d'accord que c'est un
amendement technique un amendement qui
vient rectifier les équilibres
budgétaires de la réforme des retraites
c'est bien ça oui c'est ça mais c'est un
texte c'est un texte important donc il
est nécessaire de prendre le temps de
regarder chaque amendement nous l'avons
fait pendant l'examen du texte il est
normal que nous puissions avoir au moins
10 minutes pour examiner même si
effectivement c'est un texte qui veut
qui veut aboutir à un équilibre ça on en
est conscient mais qu'on nous laisse
quand même le temps de travailler ce
texte le regarder parce qu'il sera
soumis quand même au vote du Sénat en
question on voit un niveau de tension
assez assez remarquable au Sénat entre
la droite et la gauche sénatoriale on
entend des remis Cardon à l'instant qui
disait qu'il y avait des attaques
abdominales envers lui et Yann
chanterelle et des attaques qui le
regrette qu'est-ce qui est en train de
se passer entre la droite et la gauche
sénatoriale c'est un avant et un après
réforme des retraites qui se joue oui
moi je pense sincèrement qu'il y a un
avant et un après le comportement de la
droite sénatoriale a été du gouvernement
d'ailleurs de façon conjuguée a été
assez terrible je voudrais dire à notre
à notre égard et de l'obstruction de
votre part de l'obstruction si présenter
des amendements on en a présenté 4000 au
total de de mémoire il y en a eu 16000 à
l'Assemblée nationale donc on met où le
curseur de l'obstruction je rejette
complètement ce terme d'ostruction nous
avons fait ce qui relève de nos
responsabilités de parlementaires et il
vous le dites la droite sénatoriale est
bien dans cette équation qu'est-ce
qu'elle a joué comme rôle
[Musique]
ça se joue autour de cette réunion il
s'agit quand même de tirer des
enseignements budgétaires et financiers
donc c'est la on a fait la réforme de
retraite pour le sujet soit équilibré
donc c'est quand même un sujet important
et donc notre bien normal que la
Commission cellulite mais c'est un
plfssr dans les autres PLFSS en réunit
pas à la commission donc il ne faut pas
surjouer il ne faut pas surjouer comme
cela voilà la présence de la commission
pas mais c'est très bien de le faire en
signes d'apaisement nous avons toujours
choisi ici le président archet tous les
présidents de séance quelle que soit
leur tendance de droite et de gauche des
vice-présidents vous savez qui ont
présidé les séances j'ai beaucoup suivi
des débats et bien ils ont fait en sorte
que le règlement soit bien respecté il y
a eu je crois aucune espèce
d'obstruction on respecte bien le
règlement et la démocratie ici
vous dites apaisé c'est bien le fait que
vous reconnaissez qu'il y a un niveau de
tension élevé entre la gauche et la
droite sénatoriale depuis mardi et le
vote de l'article 7 alors non moi je
vous avais les débats continuent on est
par exemple sur le texte en ce moment et
on reprendra ça ce soir
un autre sujet pour les collectivités
locales très important de le dire c'est
que nous avons repris notre rythme
normal il y a beaucoup de dansions
se plaint de la façon dont sont traitées
les parlementaires avec le rapport de la
commission esparitaire distribué à 8h25
un amendement de cette page avec les
équilibres financiers
souvent comme cela si on veut faire
adopter le texte vite c'est vrai que la
CNP aurait peut-être pu se réunir après
demain mais je comprends que le
gouvernement était pressé d'en finir non
mais simplement il n'y a pas de surprise
c'est le texte du Sénat dont je crois
qu'ils ont suivi pendant plus d'une
centaine d'heures les débats
ils connaissent le résultat de des
amendements depuis vendredi ou l'article
44 a été
enclenché par le gouvernement de la
Constitution et donc voilà il y a pas de
découverte donc faut pas surjouer et
faire les vierge et ferrochés
j'ai envie sur ce qui se passe dans
votre famille politique parce
qu'effectivement le vote on peut le dire
il est acquis au Sénat ce matin
lorsqu'il interviendra autour de ses
conclusions de la commission exporter il
est beaucoup plus incertain à
l'Assemblée nationale et c'est votre
groupe politique les républicains qui
jouent un rôle pivot et on voit une
vingtaine de députés qui pourraient
voter contre la réforme seulement 30
députés qui pourraient voter pour
qu'est-ce que ça dit lorsque la réforme
du Sénat votée par la droite sénatoriale
n'est pas voté dans les mêmes termes par
vos députés à l'Assemblée nationale il y
a des circonstances locales il y a des
particularistes mais c'est vrai que en
ce moment la famille a besoin de se
recentrer et certains sont un peu sous
pression localement il faut savoir si on
cède à la pression le texte est bon la
commission des affaires sociales vient
de sortir je reviens les apercevoir et
donc ça va reprendre votons déjà ici il
y aura le temps à l'Assemblée on vient
bien ce qui se passe la responsabilité
pour cette dizaines de députés LR qui
pourraient voter contre une réforme qui
vient de la droite et du centre
sénatorial il faudra que votre famille
politique vous savez à force d'exclure
on va se retrouver vraiment tout seul
non non le vrai sujet c'est de
comprendre pourquoi ils l'ont pas voulu
voter dès le départ alors que à un
moment il voulait voter merci Jérôme
Bachard je vous libère puisque
effectivement on a entendu la sonnerie
retentir dans les couloirs du Palais du
Luxembourg c'est le signe que la séance
va reprendre d'un instant à l'autre dans
l'hémicycle mathiasarès peut-être que
vous êtes avec moi Mathias vous pouvez
me dire ce que vous voyez vous de votre
poste d'observation la tribune de presse
de l'hémicycle je suis avec vous Quentin
effectivement ça y est les sénateurs
sont en train de reprendre place le
gouvernement c'est installé et vous
l'avez entendu Gérard lâcher l'a annoncé
la séance et reprise après un peu plus
de 15 minutes de suspension
sur l'amendement du Gouvernement merci
monsieur le Président donc la commission
des affaires sociales du Sénat s'est
réunie je voudrais dire que la vie est
favorable mais je voudrais comment vous
faire part d'un certain nombre de
réflexions que je me suis faite à la
suite de cette interruption je pense que
on a manqué de méthode par rapport à
cette présentation et j'en prends ma
part j'en prends ma part mais je pense
monsieur les ministres qu'on aurait dû
déjà avoir après
les les amendements qui ont été votés au
Sénat un premier tableau pour justement
informer nos collègues de l'ensemble des
traductions des prises de décision du
Sénat et puis ensuite je voudrais dire
aussi que apporter un amendement qui
comporte autant de pages c'est vrai que
c'est peu imaginable de pouvoir les lire
en quelques minutes alors que finalement
il y a qu'une ligne budgétaire qui
change et donc il faut qu'on trouve des
méthodes différentes parce que arrivé
sur un texte aussi important sur en
définitive un amendement qui est posé là
quelques minutes avant finalement le
vote final j'ai trouvé que la méthode
était effectivement contestable très
contestable et je vous en fais pas merci
merci
avant de passer aux explications de vote
sur l'ensemble je vais mettre aux voix
cet amendement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
une abstention
donc amendement était adopté nous allons
passer aux explications de votre des
groupes je rappelle la raison d'un
orateur par groupe tout d'abord madame
la présidente Catherine de roche pour le
groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la rapporteur général
monsieur le rapporteur madame la
rapporteur pour avis chers collègues la
commission mixte paritaire qui s'est
déroulée hier a marqué une étape
importante dans le parcours d'un texte
qui apprend un examen tronqué à
l'Assemblée nationale suivi d'un longue
examen au Sénat qui la conduit à plus
que doublé de volume à poursuivi le
cheminement ordinaire de la procédure
parlementaire
réunie pendant plus de 8h30 la
commission mixte paritaire a procédé à
une revue attentive de tous les articles
au fil notamment des différentes
propositions de suppression nos
collègues députés empêché de débattre en
première lecture du recul de l'âge légal
des carrières longues ou encore des
équilibres financiers du texte ont cette
fois pu y procéder permettant aux
différentes sensibilités de s'exprimer
avant de passer au vote
cela a été rappelé à de nombreuses
reprises mais le Sénat soucieux de la
pérennité de notre modèle social et de
notre capacité collective en faire
bénéficier les générations futures
portent cette réforme de longue date les
évolutions démographiques et sociales
nous y oblige alors que l'émergence de
besoins sociaux accrus liés au
vieillissement à la santé ou encore à la
nécessité d'intervenir dans notre
jeunesse et dans l'avenir de notre pays
ne nous permet pas de nous permettre pas
de dégager des marches supplémentaires
pour le financement des retraites comme
je l'indiquais dans la discussion
générale notre choix de consacrer une
part très importante de notre richesse
nationale aux retraites relèvent d'un
choix implicite il ne revient
aujourd'hui de clarifier d'interroger de
discuter une part des gains d'espérance
de vie qui se poursuivent doit dès lors
être mobilisé pour le bien commun et
au-delà des atténuations des effets de
la réforme le texte porte des avancées
pour les apprentis les stagiaires les
étudiants ou les élus locaux il
s'inscrit dans une tendance jamais
démentie d'élargissement et
d'enrichissement de notre système social
au total le texte issu de la CMP propose
une réforme qui garantit l'avenir notre
système de retraite sans toutefois faire
peser l'effort sur ceux qui ne
pourraient le supporter c'est pourquoi
le groupe les républicains invite le
Sénat votait ce texte et apprendre ses
responsabilités avec courage comme il
l'a fait de manière constante nous
sommes conscients que ce texte marque
une étape et qu'il doit s'accompagner de
changements profonds dans la prise en
compte des salariés les plus âgés dans
une économie en pénurie de main d'oeuvre
il est évident qu'ils ont toute leur
place ce chantier avant tout celui des
entreprises et des partenaires sociaux
avant d'être celui de la loi néanmoins
si des changements législatifs s'avèrent
nécessaire nous répond rons présents
comme nous l'avons fait sur la santé au
travail sur l'assurance chômage et sur
toutes les réformes affectant le
fonctionnement du marché du travail la
retraite ne s'arrête le seul horizon
pour les jeunes qui ont dit cela toute
leur vie à construire je vous remercie
merci madame la Présidente
[Applaudissements]
pour les républicains on passe à Colette
Melo qui représente le groupe Les
Indépendants la droite Macron compatible
le groupe de Monsieur Malhuret au Sénat
Colette Melo qui dispose elle aussi de 5
minutes pour donner l'opinion de son
groupe sur la corde de la CMP
madame la rapporteur monsieur le
rapporteur madame la Présidente de la
Commission mes chers collègues
plus de senteurs de débat au Sénat
plusieurs milliers d'amendements
examinés 10 jours de discussion enfin
nous y sommes enfin ce PLF RSS trouve
une issue la commission mixte paritaire
s'est réunie hier nous devons désormais
voter le texte qui en résulte c'est
pourquoi je le dis d'emblée notre groupe
votera pour cette réforme des retraites
notre objectif n'est pas de vendre du
rêve aux Français mais bien de fonder la
politique sur la réalité cette réalité
elle est limpide il y avait quatre
actifs pour un retraité dans les années
60 trois cotisants pour un retraité dans
les années 70 en 2023 ils sont 1,7 pour
un cotisant face à ce constat qui peut
croire que notre modèle social en l'état
et pérenne il ne l'est pas le
gouvernement se devait d'agir le choix
était binaire augmenter les prélèvements
c'était pénalisé le pouvoir d'achat des
Français dans un contexte déjà difficile
augmenter le temps de travail
des Français rester donc la seule
solution réaliste alors que l'espérance
de vie progresse encore cela participe à
sauver notre régime par répartition et à
préserver le pouvoir d'achat des
Français nous saluons ainsi le report de
l'âge légal de deux ans il s'agit d'une
nécessité pour l'équilibre de notre
système nous regrettons toutefois que
l'ajout d'une dose de capitalisation
collective dans notre système par
répartition n'est pas été retenue il
nous faudra à l'avenir réfléchir à cette
question si de nombreux Français se sont
inquiétés de certains aspects de cette
réforme notamment sur les carrières
longues la commission mixte paritaire
est parvenue à trouver une solution à ce
sujet le groupe Les Indépendants avaient
choisi lors des débats de porter un
amendement favorisant les carrières
longues idées partagées par de nombreux
sénateurs nous nous réjouissons donc que
le dispositif adopté permettent à tous
ceux et en cotisés au moins cinq
trimestres avant 21 ans de partir plus
tôt sans avoir à cotiser plus de 43 à
nuités le coût est important de l'ordre
de 700 millions d'euros nous venons de
le voir à l'horizon 2030 mais cette
mesure a le mérite de donner plus de
lisibilité à la réforme et dans garantir
l'équité c'est la preuve que le
compromis le consensus sont possibles
par ailleurs ce texte contient plusieurs
mesures de justice sociale les régimes
spéciaux auraient été avaient été conçus
à des périodes où les circonstances
l'imposer en raison de mauvaises
conditions de travail de nombreux
progrès ont été faits en la matière ce
qui justifie la suppression progressive
des régimes spéciaux le régime général
apparaît désormais plus juste pour
l'ensemble des Français nous saluons
donc le maintien de cet article par la
CMP nous saluons également la surcotte
alors jusqu'à 5% pour les maires de
famille ayant réalisé une carrière
complète c'était une nécessité elle
vient combler un manque dommage à ces
femmes qui tout en travaillant pour
subvenir aux besoins de leur famille
participent activement à l'éducation de
leurs enfants il est d'ailleurs juste
d'avoir étendu aux professions libérales
la majoration de 10% de la pension à
partir du 3e enfant tout comme il est
juste d'avoir intégré les indemnités
journalières de maternité dans le calcul
de la pension nous nous réjouissons de
l'adoption de l'assurance vieillesse
pour les aidants qui va bénéficier après
de 40 000 personnes par an c'est un
dispositif que nous soutenons et qui va
dans le bon sens même si certains
d'entre nous auraient souhaité qu'il
aille plus loin de plus la prise en
compte d'une majoration de trimestres
trop bénéfices des pompiers volontaires
représentent une avance et tout à fait
justifiée que nous avions nous-mêmes
défendu
sceptique sur le CDI senior qui a été
proposé nous sommes rassurés de
constater qu'il a été maintenu mais à
titre expérimental cela permettra d'en
juger l'efficacité avant de généraliser
éventuellement le dispositif dans le
même registre l'index senior peut être
Natoo nous ne doutons pas que cette
politique volontariste en faveur de
l'emploi des seniors trouvera son
aboutissement dans la future loi travail
les échanges entre les générations sont
une richesse pour les entreprises et
doivent être encouragés ainsi toutes ces
mesures cette réforme avec toutes ces
mesures cette réforme des retraites est
juste et s'inscrit dans le pacte social
français elle est un moyen de garantir
la pérennité de notre système de
retraite ce qui est indispensable le
groupe Les Indépendants votera
l'adoption de ce texte je vous remercie
merci ma chère collègues
[Applaudissements]
pour explication de vote madame Raymond
de ponts et Monge
pour le groupe écologique
solidarité et territoire
voilà Raymonde poncer monche qui va
prendre la parole pour les écologistes
allez elle est connue on l'a beaucoup
entendu pendant les jours de cette
réforme de retraite elle a dû porter à
elle seule plus de 500 amendements pour
son groupe on va l'écouter le texte
soumis au vote du Parlement aujourd'hui
et le fruit d'une CMP sans suspense où
l'opposition a pris connaissance du
résultat des réaménagements à la marge
pour assurer les votes de la droite dans
les deux chambres négocier à la monte
avec le gouvernement dans le cadre d'un
budget alloué aux mesures d'atténuation
de la brutalité de la réforme nous avons
assisté au compromis final troquant une
mesure contre une autre tout en
préservant la philosophie générale
travailler plus par le report de l'âge
ouvrant droit à la retraite de 62 à 64
ans
ainsi le CDI senior du Sénat a été
contenu à une expérimentation pour
libérer quelques centaines de millions
pour un meilleur calibrage des carrières
longues conditionnant quelques votes à
l'Assemblée nationale nous soutenons pas
la première mesure et constatant que la
seconde n'a pas atteint son but nous
remarquons néanmoins que la droite
sénatoriale a consenti abandonné une
partie de ses amendements et remaniement
du texte pour éviter un 49,3 à
l'Assemblée nationale après avoir
consenti aux 44 3 au Sénat
défendu depuis plusieurs années cette
réforme valait bien quelques sacrifices
du rôle du Parlement le cœur de la
réforme est inchangé quant à son
injustice et sa brutalité comme sa
dimension productivisme puisque son
impact annoncé a été évalué au gain d'un
point de PIB un point de pays B au prix
de pour beaucoup d'un prolongement du
sas de précarité de pauvreté d'une
explosion des arrêts maladie de longue
durée du chômage du basculement dans les
minimes soit un coût social inédit une
fracture sociale approfondie
ignorée par les partisans de la réforme
qui n'ont rien d'autre à proposer qu'un
index non contraignant une
expérimentation CDI fin de carrière
prétexte de nouvelles exonération et une
boude surcote contre la liberté de
partir à la retraite
un point de PIB
vantez à coup de mensonges sur les 1200
euros et de marchandages en 3D droite et
le gouvernement pour troquer je l'ai dit
une mesure d'atténuation contre une
autre dans l'objectif toujours partagé
de réaliser l'économie des dépenses
sociales qui financera infinies les
nouvelles belles impôts des plus
fortunés
un point de PIB en imposant une
augmentation contrainte de l'offre de
travail
en imposant la concurrence entre
travailleurs pour faire pression sur les
salaires après avoir dérégululé le
marché du travail permis à dégradation
des conditions de travail et voter une
restriction des droits au chômage
un point de pays B à contre-courant
ignorant les transformations sociétales
et sociales en cours la crise de
l'attractivité les vagues de démission
et le Bold face à la subordination
salariale au manque d'autonomie dans le
travail et de sens au travail un point
de PIB que vous gravillez encore sur le
travail aggravant le partage inégal des
richesses alors que la ponction des
dividendes explose et capte justement de
plus en plus de points de PIB un point
de PIB parce que vous ignorez la
diversité et l'utilité des services non
marchands et le logiciel nouveau pour
relever les défis sociaux et climatiques
de notre siècle
un poil de PIB contre les préconisations
du GIEC arrachées à la terre alors que
la France dépasse déjà 6 des notes
limites planétaires et alors que ça
grave les inégalités de patrimoine
inconciliables avec la bifurcation
écologique
un point de pays B parce que vous êtes
prisonnier d'un logiciel productiviste
incapable d'imaginer une prospérité sans
croissance ou serait possible et même
nécessaire une réduction du temps de
travail
un point de PIB en fin on bafouant les
corps intermédiaires acteurs
représentatif de la démocratie sociale
moderne en brutalisant le Parlement en
ignorant le refus radical du peuple
français de cette réforme en imposant
comme si ce n'était qu'un mauvais moment
a passé vous vous trompez votre refus de
l'alternative à cette impasse à savoir
le recours au référendum et de nouveau
un abus de faiblesse retirez votre
projet ou soumettez-le au référendum car
vous n'avez pas de mandat du peuple
français pour cette réforme le groupe le
groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire
votera compte bien entendu mais vous
appelle monsieur le ministre à la
responsabilité et on retrait de votre
réforme je vous remercie merci
[Musique]
la parole est maintenant notre colère
après cette prise de parole de la chef
de fil des écologistes sur la réforme de
retraite c'est au tour de la majorité
présidentielle représentée par Xavier
Comelli un groupe RDPI c'est-à-dire le
groupe des marcheurs au Sénat et qui va
s'exprimer sur cette réforme monsieur
les ministres madame et monsieur le
rapporteur madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales mes
chers collègues nous arrivons au terme
de ce débat sur la réforme des retraites
74 heures de débat à l'Assemblée 109 au
Sénat 9h en commission mix paritaire
personne ne pourra nier le fait que nous
avons eu le temps de débattre sur le
fond certains ont remis même en cause la
légitimité des outils de notre
Constitution ou de notre règlement
intérieur mais l'obstruction d'une
minorité n'aura pas empêché la majorité
d'entre nous qui souhaitons améliorer le
texte et de faire pourquoi ce pourquoi
nous sommes élus c'est-à-dire voter la
loi
et je me félicite mes chers collègues
que nous ayons abouti à ce sur ce texte
car c'est le fruit d'un travail
parlementaire le fruit de travail de
toutes les sensibilités de notre chambre
en trouvant un compromis nous avons
répondu à la nécessité d'équilibrer
notre système de retraite tout en
assurant des droits et des progrès
nouveaux
le travail est au coeur de cette réforme
et vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
ministre alors que certains considèrent
que le travail est une contrainte et une
soumission un système qui exploite les
citoyens nous nous voyons dans le
travail le fait que celui-ci donne un
rôle et une place dans la société qui
crée du lien social et qui offre les
conditions d'émancipation et de dignité
parce que oui mes chers collègues
beaucoup de nos concitoyens
s'épanouissent dans leur vie active et
ils y trouvent un sens et une place dans
notre société et il n'y a pas de déni
dans mes propos certains métiers sont
moins épanouis sans que d'autres
certains sont plus usants et plus
pénibles et il faut donc adapter notre
système à ses publics fragile et c'est
ce que nous avons fait dans ce projet de
loi
nous avons voulu accès nos travaux sur
des points qui sont essentiels et qui
sont synonymes d'avancer de solidarité
pour les Françaises et les Français tout
d'abord on renforçant les droits
familiaux avec la création de la
surcotte sur les pour les mers qui
auraient travaillé une durée d'assurance
requise à 63 ans sur l'extension aux
professionnels aux professions libérale
pardon de la majoration de 10% de la
passion la pension à partir du troisième
enfant ou encore avec la prise en compte
du congé maternité nous avons aussi
souhaité après un débat en commission
mixparitaire garder la proposition de la
présidente billon sur la privation de
l'attribution de trimestres pour les
parents condamnés pour violence et
maltraitance à l'encontre de son enfant
ou encore la fixation d'un minimum de
deux trimestres ou de majorations au
titre de l'éducation des enfants au
bénéfice de la mer porté par la
présidente Rossignol protégeant de fait
les femmes
nous avons souhaité soutenir les publics
les plus fragiles notamment avec la
version de pension pour les orphelins
avec des mesures spécifiques pour les
enfants porteurs de handicap ou la
revalorisation des retraites et de
l'ASPA à Mayotte portée par notre
collègue tannie Mohamed Souali nous
avons porté également plusieurs mesures
pour rendre notre système plus juste
avec une meilleure prise en compte des
carrières hachées par le renforcement
des droits à la retraite pour les
aidants pour l'attribution de la durée
d'assurance au titre de l'éducation en
cas de décès de l'enfant par
l'intégration des périodes d'emploi des
stagiaires et des apprentis dans le
calcul des droits à la retraite et enfin
la majoration pour la retraite pour les
sapeurs-pompiers mais aussi et ça a fait
longuement débats par l'assouplissement
du dispositif carrière longue en
ajoutant une barrière à 18 ans et à 21
ans qui s'ajoute à celle existante de 16
ans et 20 ans ainsi qu'en supprimant le
dispositif de la loi Touraine imposant
jusqu'à deux ans de plus de la durée de
cotisation
pardon de la durée de situation ce ayant
travaillé à partir de 16 ans plus aucune
personne ayant travaillé avant 21 ans ne
sera obligé de aller plus loin que la
durée de cotisation de 43 à nuités cette
réforme permettra également une prise en
compte de l'usure professionnelle par
l'élargissement de l'accès aux comptes
professionnels de prévention et par la
création d'un fond inédit
d'investissement d'un milliard pour la
prévention ce texte mes chers collègues
a été considérablement enrichi la par la
lecture du Sénat renforçant ainsi le
rôle de notre chambre de la fabrique de
la loi
notre système par répartition tout
entier et bien bâti sur la solidarité
solidarité intergénérationnelle entre
actif et retraité nous votons pour une
société plus solidaire prospère et
pérenne devant une réalité démographique
implacable monsieur le ministre vous
l'avez rappelé nous faisons le choix de
la responsabilité face aux déséquilibres
notre de nos finances publiques nous
faisons le choix du travail
confronté au risque d'une paupérisation
sociale nous faisons le choix de
l'équité parce que nous valoriserons
toujours le travail face à la taxation
excessive notre groupe votera en faveur
de ce texte et les conclusions de la CMP
je vous remercie merci
donner la parole à notre collègue
Monique Lubin c'est maintenant un
Monique Lubin chef de fil des
socialistes de s'exprimer sur la réforme
des retraites il reste encore un deux
trois quatre orateurs ensuite pour aller
jusqu'au vote des conclusions de cette
commission mixte paritaire parole au
socialistes
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
monsieur le rapporteur
j'avais travaillé un texte
pour ma discussion générale comme nous
le faisons en règle générale
seulement voilà
je ne l'utiliserai pas
parce que j'ai entendu les propos des
ministres
parce que j'ai entendu d'autres propos
et donc finalement je n'utiliserai pas
ce que j'avais prévu je vous parlerai
plutôt avec mes tripes
monsieur le monsieur le ministre du soft
vous avez pris soin d'expliquer à quel
point le débat c'était mal passé dans
nos deux assemblées alors bien sûr vous
avez dit toujours en parlant du Sénat
que c'était dans une moindre mesure ici
mais vous avez quand même critiqué la
façon dont nous avait dont nous avons
travaillé or nous avons travaillé très
très sérieusement les oppositions comme
la majorité j'imagine on travaillait
très sérieusement on préparait leur
sujet pendant des semaines alors oui
alors oui monsieur le ministre nous
avons utilisé ce que nous pouvions
utiliser c'est-à-dire notre droit
d'amendement parce que si nous n'avions
pas utilisé notre droit d'amendement je
ne vois pas bien comment nous aurions pu
débattre de ce sujet vous aviez tout
fait en commençant par le choix du
véhicule législatif pour nous empêcher
d'aller au fond de ce sujet et de
débattre le plus longtemps possible vous
aviez tout fait pour réduire donc oui
nous avons rajouté des amendements parce
que nous voulions oui vous pousser
jusque dans vos retranchements et si
nous voulions faire ça c'est parce que
nous accompagnons le mouvement social et
ces millions de salariés qui ne veulent
pas du report de l'âge de la retraite
vous nous parlez
quant à vous monsieur le ministre Attal
comme d'habitude vous vous nous
promettez l'enfer comme d'habitude la
faillite l'enfer tout ça n'est pas
sérieux voilà nous savons qu'il y aura
effectivement peut-être
des déficits à l'aune de 13 milliards
d'euros dans quelques années et nous
nous avons proposé d'autres possibilités
pour combler ces déficits ça vous fait
beaucoup sourire mais je pense que les
salariés aujourd'hui n'auront pas envie
de rire quant à la CMP on nous dit la
CMP d'hier a permis de trouver un
compromis une CMP c'est une CMP tout le
monde ici c'est comment ça se passe et
de quoi il s'agit donc les compromis ils
n'ont pas été trouvés hier dans la
journée la CMP elle a duré parce qu'une
fois de plus nous vous avons obligé nous
avons contraint à aller sur tous les
articles mais tout était bouclé hier
matin et tout était bouclé non pas dans
l'intérêt des salariés tout était bouclé
dans l'intérêt du gouvernement et du
président de la République parce qu'en
fait
il s'agissait décidément je vous le dis
chers amis c'est très rigolo ce que je
veux dire ça rit beaucoup sur les bancs
et parce qu'en fait tout ce qu'il
fallait c'était sauver la face tellement
votre projet de loi est mal engagé
depuis des mois tellement il est mal
perçu par la population donc la CMP
d'hier c'était pour sauver la face la
réforme j'y viens mais vous nous avez
suffisamment entendu nous ne voulons pas
des 64 ans parce que c'est 64 ans vont
pénaliser ceux qui travaillent depuis
longtemps donc ceux qui ont les métiers
les plus difficiles et ceux qui
perçoivent les salaires les moins élevés
alors vous avez apporté des mesures on
va dire d'atténuation les contrats
seniors mais les contratseniors une fois
de plus payés par d'autres notamment si
j'ai bien compris maintenant plus ou
moins la branche ATMP les contrats
seniors qui verront encore faire des
cadeaux aux entreprises comme si on ne
leur faisait pas assez comme si
maintenant le recrutement dans les
entreprises était seulement soumis aux
cadeaux fiscaux et sociaux qu'on leur
ferait
les surcottes pour les femmes les
surcottes pour les femmes alors la
franchement
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion d'expliquer
plusieurs fois qu'aujourd'hui une femme
qui arrive à 62 ans avec tous ces
trimestres qui décide de travailler
jusqu'à 64 ans à 10 % de surcotte là
elle décidera plus elle y sera obligée
et on lui donnera royalement 5% de
surcotes
les petites pensions les petites
pensions mais qu'elles fiasco mais
quelle fiasco après nous avoir raconté
que 2 millions de Français qui ont les
plus petites pensions verrez leur
retraite s'améliorer alors que nous
savons que ce n'est pas vrai quant aux
carrière longue
quant aux carrière longue je suis désolé
de vous dire malgré tous vos efforts que
personne n'y comprend rien personne n'y
comprend rien nous espérons qu'un grand
nombre en bénéficiera parce
qu'effectivement parce qu'effectivement
l'objet de ce de ce texte c'est de
toucher à ceux qui travaillent déjà
depuis longtemps ma conclusion comment
allez-vous réparer ce pays que vous êtes
en train durablement de fracturer
ce discours de la salle de fil des
socialistes au Sénat c'est autour
maintenant des communistes avec Cathy à
poursu poli vous voyez à chaque fois ce
sont non pas les présidents de groupe
politique mais les chefs de styles sur
le texte de chacun des groupes
politiques qui s'expriment
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président cher collègue sans
surprise la commission mix paritaire a
trouvé un accord sur cette réforme des
retraites à 10 sur 14 vous avez voté les
64 ans quelle légitimité rien d'étonnant
puisque républicain
comment républicain centriste et
Renaissance sont favorables à
l'allongement de l'âge légal à 64 ans
nous allons examiner les conclusions de
la CMP sans la mise en ligne du rapport
mais bon sur les bords de la droite
pluriennes vous gêne rapport ou pas vous
voterez lors de cette scène payer
d'ailleurs à l'article 14 alors que
celle-ci était loin d'être terminée vous
avez sorti un communiqué annonçant une
CMP
conclusive il aura fallu moins de temps
au CMP pour dîner l'avenir de notre pays
qu'il n'en a fallu au Sénat pour déposer
un amendement de réécriture de l'article
qui a fait tomber 1300 amendements nous
n'oublions pas non plus que la majorité
présidentielle et la majorité
sénatoriale veulent imposer une réforme
à laquelle sont opposées 70% des
Français et 90% des actifs cette
minorité politique a décidé à une
majorité je le disais de 10 sur 14 en
commission mixte paritaire du sort de
notre avenir à la crise sociale et
environnementale le gouvernement les
droites parlementaires ont donc décidé
d'ajouter une crise parlementaire et une
crise démocratique vous imposez une
régression sociale en ayant recours aux
artifices de la Constitution et du
Règlement du Sénat depuis deux mois le
peuple vous dit non il était encore des
milliers dans la ruillère pour la 8ème
fois pour refuser votre projet nous
avons dénoncé votre projet injuste
inefficace et impopulaire mais votre
obsession s'est transformée en aveugle
le texte issu de la CMP acte une réforme
profondément injuste qui va s'appliquer
dès le premier septembre et contrainte
des milliers de concitoyens de retarder
leur peau de départ en retraite de deux
ans le gouvernement a donc accepté le
contrat de fin de carrière des
républicains en 2006 un contrat du même
type avait été instauré pour un résultat
nul le gouvernement devrait mettre
autant d'énergie à lutter contre la
frotte patronale au cotisations sociales
et contre l'évasion fiscale les sommes
recouvraient permettrait de financer
notre système de retraite sans imposer
deux années supplémentaires de vie
brisés contrairement aux affirmations du
ministre Gabriel Attal l'équilibre du
système de retraite n'est nullement
garanti par cette réforme l'équilibre
est assuré par la baisse de la
subvention d'équilibre de l'État au
régime de retraite et notamment le gel
du point d'indice des fonctionnaires et
la réduction du nombre de fonctionnaires
territoriaux et hospitalier votre dogme
libéral vous fait perdre la raison ce
sont les politiques d'austérité qui ont
entraîné le déséquilibre de notre
système de retraite je rappelle que le
Conseil d'orientation des retraites
détails dans son rapport les mesures
d'économie sur la masse salariale
publique se traduisent par une
détérioration du solde du système de
retraite ce sont les choix fait par la
droite sous Nicolas Sarkozy qui
permettent aujourd'hui au parlementaire
les républicains d'exiger la
généralisation de la capitalisation dans
notre système par répartition le refus
de mettre un contribution les plus
riches le refus de mettre un
contribution les dividendes le refus
d'élargir l'assiette de cotisations
démontent les intérêts de ceux que vous
protégez vous avez même refusé
l'augmentation de la cotisation
employeur pourtant proposée par le Haut
Commissariat au Plan pour garantir la
pérennité du système de retraite vous
faites passer les intérêts dossier avant
la prise en compte de la pénibilité des
inégalités salariales entre les femmes
et les hommes la suppression des régimes
spéciaux est une vision éclairante de la
manière dont vous concevez la prise en
compte de la pénibilité des métiers en
conclusion nous avons assisté à un
marché dupe entre le gouvernement et les
républicains qui ont renoncé à leur
amendement sur les carrières longues et
la prise en compte des risques chimiques
vous portez un projet de classe contre
les travailleurs et les travailleurs la
fébrilité du pouvoir monte avec la
menace de 49,3 de plus en plus menaçant
avec le gouvernement vous pouvez
utiliser tous les coups de force
anti-démocratique comme vous l'avez fait
ici vous ne convaincraiez pas les
français du bien fondé de votre réforme
qui vise à les faire travailler jusque
64 ans bien au contraire le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste
s'opposera jusqu'au bout à cette réforme
et soutiendra le mouvement social
merci
voilà vous l'entendez la gauche
sénatoriale qui s'oppose à cette réforme
on tiendra ces termes de Katia pour ce
poli n'oublions pas que le gouvernement
et la majorité sénatoriale veulent
imposer une réforme à laquelle 70% des
Français sont opposés c'est au tour des
centristes de s'exprimer
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres madame monsieur le les
rapporteur madame la Présidente de
commission chers collègues nous y voilà
nous abordons la toute dernière ligne
droite de ce texte sur la réforme des
retraites notre groupe Union centriste
votre âme majoritairement ce texte
mes premiers mots seront pour dire que
nous avons le Sénat la majorité
sénatoriale était à la hauteur de
l'enjeu sourd à la démagogie vous savez
la démagogie je vous écoutez chers
collègues dont le triomphe est passager
les ruines éternelles disaient Peggy
j'irai même
plus loin le Sénat la majorité
sénatoriale a donné le la tel un
diapason sur ce texte l'occasion bien
sûr de saluer de remercier nos
rapporteurs pour la qualité de leur
travail et leurs connaissances du
dossier retraite ils l'ont démontré tout
au long de du débat de la CMP et puis
encore à l'instant en commission
sur le texte lui-même mes chers
collègues je persiste les signes il ne
mérite pas toute cette indignation qu'il
suscite il le justifie pas non plus un
enthousiasme démesuré ni le diable ni la
mère des réformes un texte et ce n'est
pas rien qui assure la survie de notre
régime par répartition et surtout un
texte qui évite à notre pays de
s'endetter pour payer ses retraites
souvent nous entendons dans cette
hémicie qu'il y a une bonne dette et une
mauvaise dette je partage cette opinion
s'endetter pour investir dans la
recherche dans les infrastructures bref
s'endetter pour l'avenir s'endetter pour
innover peut avoir une dimension
vertueuse mais sans d'été pour le
fonctionnement c'est irresponsable et
c'est compromettent l'avenir cela nous
est interdit d'ailleurs dans les
collectivités territoriales sous peine
d'être mis sous tutelle mais pour moi
pour nous s'endetter pour payer les
retraites c'est le comble de
l'irresponsabilité c'est une honte pour
les plus jeunes générations
cette affirmation toute simple donne
sens au vote de ce texte j'ai entendu
beaucoup parler chers collègues pendant
cette discussion et puis même à
l'instant et cette citation de
Shakespeare me revenait les mots ne
payent pas les dettes chers collègues
les mots ne payent pas les dettes ce
texte
donne de la solidité pour plusieurs
années à notre système de retraite par
répartition notons les avancées je vais
assez vite parce qu'elles ont été
abordés la question de l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes la question de
l'emploi des seniors avec un dispositif
d'incitation des trimestres excusés du
peu pour les tuques les aidants les élus
qui gagnent moins de 1830 euros par mois
la pénibilité et puis les carrières
longues avec C43 ans mais alors pourquoi
ce texte avec ses avancées ce texte qui
au total concerne six Français sur 10 et
pas ceux dont les métiers sont les plus
pénibles pourquoi ce texte suscite-t-il
autant de tension nous y voyons
plusieurs causes notre système de
retraite est injuste mais c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui
lorsqu'il y a eu la réforme Touraine on
vous a peu entendu sur l'injustice du
système de retraite et donc ce système
de retraite est injuste il les moins à
l'issue de cette réforme mais il faudra
encore continuer à avancer vers plus de
justice une autre cause c'est que nous
attendons peut-être trop de de
des retraites une réforme des retraites
ne peut pas corriger toutes les
injustices de la société française de
notre système social et enfin et surtout
la cause de ces tensions pour notre
groupe c'est le manque de dialogue
social et la crise du paritarisme c'est
selon nous la faute originelle de
l'exécutif d'avoir enjambé les causes
les corps intermédiaires c'est pourquoi
nous appelons à l'ouverture d'une
conférence sociale après le vote de ce
texte les sujets sociaux sur la table
sont importants et nombreux le travail
valeur contrainte on en a débattu tout
au long de de ces derniers jours la
rémunération des salariés le cadre de
gestion de l'assurance chômage l'emploi
des seniors est encore beau de plus
d'autres la santé le logement sur toutes
ces questions la société française a
besoin d'apaisement et cet apaisement
passe par l'imparitarisme et a dit la
langue sociale refonder et rénovée voilà
mes chers collègues pour conclure je
veux vous faire partager mon sentiment
différent de ce que j'ai entendu à
l'instant
sentiment d'avoir vécu un beau moment
parlementaire un vrai moment
parlementaire ici au Sénat nous avons
fait honneur mes chers collègues au
bicamérisme le Sénat représente les
territoires et c'est son honneur le
Sénat représente les territoires et
c'est son honneur mais nous avons
apporté la réponse la plus forte à ceux
qui nous ont parfois caricaturés en
Bundes strat nous sommes un parlement de
plein droit et surtout un pilier de la
République vive le Sénat vive la
république mes chers collègues je vous
remercie merci
voilà il est 10h31 à l'antenne de Public
Sénat si vous nous rejoignez nous sommes
en direct pour suivre la lecture et le
vote autour des conclusions de la
commission mix paritaire qui était
réunie hier donc une journée importante
pour l'exécutif important aussi pour
l'avenir de la réforme des retraites
mais on l'entend la droite et le centre
qui se revendiquent de la paternité de
beaucoup des mesures qui sont dans le
texte final et qui donc vont appeler à
voter cette réforme des retraites au
Sénat c'est un vote que vous suivrez
bien sûr sur notre antenne la parole est
au Stéphane Ravier votre crucial pour
éviter d'infliger de nouveaux sacrifices
ça nous compatriotes et mettre le
gouvernement assez responsabilités votre
crucial en vue de réconcilier la
démocratie parlementaire avec les
Français vote crucial pour la droite qui
peut enfin envoyer le message qu'elle
n'est pas là pour servir la soupe à
Emmanuel Macron votre crucial pour la
gauche en vue d'expier sa faute d'avoir
appelé à voter pour le candidat Macron
en 2022 et d'avoir voulu empêcher le
vote du texte une tenue parlementaire
d'aussi mauvais goût que sa tenue
vestimentaire en réalité
en réalité dois-je vous le rappeler mes
chers collègues nous sommes des hommes
et des femmes libres moi en tout cas je
le suis l'exécutif lui est piégé car
Bercy a promis cette réforme des
retraites à la Commission européenne
pour bénéficier du plan de relance et du
quoi qu'il en coûte il est obligé de
faire cette réforme désormais c'est une
réforme économique idéologique pas une
réforme sociale fera sans nous en tout
cas il la fera sans moi nous voilà
pièces et poils liés à Madame
vanderleyen et l'Union européenne alors
que notre participation nette à son
budget et de 10 milliards d'euros par an
en voilà des économies je ne dis pas à
la réalité problématique du système par
répartition il n'y a qu'un 7 actifs pour
un retraité aujourd'hui c'est vrai
cependant ce n'est pas la faute des
Français si pour se plier aux exigences
de l'ultralibéralisme les gouvernements
ont abandonnés depuis 30 ans notre est
de tissu agricole et industriel à une
concurrence étrangère déloyale je tends
des millions de Français au chômage et
nous privant ainsi d'autant de cotisants
reporter l'âge de la de départ à la
retraite c'est demander plus d'efforts
aux Français pour s'éviter de tailler
dans les gisements d'économie tabou car
les économies il y en a à faire sur la
fraude sociale 20 à 30 milliards sur la
fraude fiscale près de 40 milliards
selon un rapport sénatorial sur le
recours robinet de conseils 2,5
milliards selon l'inspection générale
des finances sur la fraude migratoire
plusieurs dizaines de milliards dans un
pays où les prélèvements obligatoires
représentent un record européen de 45%
du PIB par facilité par paresse par
couardise aucune réflexion n'est engagée
par l'État pour baisser les cotisations
qui pèsent sur notre croissance comme
les précédents le gouvernement actuel
préfère sacrifier les travailleurs et
les maires de famille plutôt que de
sacrifier son allégeance européiste en
engageant les réformes structurelles
nécessaires et urgente c'est-à-dire
revenir à un état stratège qui protège
le présent et prévoit l'avenir en
soutenant l'industrie le monde de
paysans créer des emplois qualifiés pour
les plus jeunes engager une politique
familiale ambitieuse encourageant la
natalité française et exclusivement
française
puisque le président fait le tour du
monde pour fuir la colère des Français
le Sénat doit lui envoyer un message
clair quand le président Macron prend
une cuite à Kinshasa ce n'est pas aux
Français à avoir la gueule de bois c'est
pourquoi mes chers collègues je vous
invite à refuser le grand déplacement en
faisant un bras d'honneur à cette
injuste projet de loi
la parole est maintenant au président
voilà Stéphane Ravier qui est siège au
groupe des non inscrits qui est proche
d'Eric Zemmour et qui était anciennement
au rassemblement national c'est
maintenant et bien le dernier orateur
Jean-Claude Ruquier pour le groupe RDSE
le groupe RDSE qui n'existe qu'au Sénat
qui est un groupe à majorité de radicaux
on l'écoute
le président la souligné samedi soir le
Sénat a consacré un peu plus de senteurs
de débats pour aller jusqu'au bout sur
l'ensemble du texte de la réforme des
retraites ce que le collègue de
l'Assemblée nationale n'ont plus faire
c'est pendant notre hémicycle aussi la
forme la trop souvent emporté sur le
fond la politesse en plus amendement
d'écrire à l'infini et petit livre vert
brandit très fréquemment toute la
palette les outils de l'obstruction
parlementaire a été utilisé
le Parlement ne sont pas grandi de cet
épisode la réforme héritée des débats
plus approfondie sur bien des aspects il
a fallu en passer par le 44 3 pour
pouvoir se penser à minima sur tous les
articles soyons lucide c'est une réforme
semble nécessaire car la logique
démographique à l'oeuvre depuis
plusieurs décennies menacent l'équilibre
financier de notre régime de retraite
c'est une évidence le système a un grand
défaut il ne supporte pas une donnée
pour autant heureuse celle de
l'allongement ou de l'espérance de vie
et d'inéquation qu'il nous faut résoudre
tout en compte de certaines situations
tous les métiers ne se valent pas c'est
que certains peuvent faire 94 ne peuvent
pas le faire car il y a exposition au
risque car il y a un accidents de la vie
car il n'y a pas suffisamment d'offres
d'emploi pour les seniors pour parce
qu'il y a des gens qui connaissent très
tôt et pour lesquels l'expression une
retraite bien méritée prend tout son
sens
la chaîne me pétition unitaire a-t-elle
réussi à trouver cet équilibre entre
nécessité et justice nos collègues sont
pas vus à l'accord c'est assez clair les
travaux de la commission portent la
marque du Sénat bien entendu fondement
du texte gouvernemental demeure et dont
le fameux article 7 sur l'âge légal de
départ ainsi que l'index seniors qui
avait été rintaudique par notre
assemblée nos collègues rapporteurs ont
explosé les principaux apports de
massemblée j'ai en y reviendrai pas si
c'est pour saluer les améliorations
concernant les carrières longues mais
aussi pour regretter le recul sur
l'usure professionnelle avec le retrait
du critère d'exposition aux agents
chimique dangereux
ses collègues la balle sera cet
après-midi dans le camp de l'Assemblée
nationale en attendant je n'avais pas
caché les différentes sensibilités qui
existent au sein de mon groupe chacun a
voté jusqu'à présent c'est aussi
ambition il en sera de même aujourd'hui
tout au long des débats nous sommes
toujours rassemblés sur les nombreux
défis de la réforme la pénibilité les
carrières longues l'emploi du seniors la
compensation de l'engagement citoyen
bénévole ou encore la possibilité de
rachat de trimestre pour différents
profits une dizaine nous amendements ont
déjà adoptés et certains qui ont survécu
assez CMP répondent à quelques-unes aux
attentes je pense aux jeunes à
l'apprentissage aux étudiants au travers
handicapés aux sapeurs-pompiers
volontaires ou encore aux femmes pour
lesquelles des aménagements ont été
apportés ce qui nous réunit aussi au
RDSE c'est l'idée que la solidarité une
valeur républicaine à laquelle nous
sommes fortement attachés continuent de
guider le régime par répartition que la
France a mis en place en 1945 et auquel
nous concitoyens restent très attachés
merci monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
voilà on vient d'assister à toutes les
explications de vote il va y avoir
maintenant un scrutin public sur
l'ensemble des conclusions de la
Commission easparita on va écouter le
président Larcher on en reparle juste
après
2023 dans la rédaction qui résulte du
texte élaboré par la commission mixte
paritaire modifiée par l'amendement du
Gouvernement en application de l'article
59 de notre règlement de scrutin public
ordinaire et de droit
scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
il est ouvert
voilà il est 10h39 nous sommes en
direction antenne de plus depuis l'ixina
pour suivre ce vote ce vote ultime
autour des conclusions de la commission
mixparitaire est-ce que l'on va
retrouver le même clivage que samedi
soir lors du vote de la réforme des
retraites je vous rappelle à l'époque on
avait 195 pour 112 contre l'ensemble de
la réforme on va voir si c'est le même
ratio autour de ces conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire donc c'est
cette députés cette sénateur qui était
réunie jusqu'à
17h40 environ hier et après 9 heures de
réunion qui s'était mis d'accord sur un
même texte entre députés et sénateurs la
droite et le centre qui sans surprise
devrait adopter les conclusions de la
commission Miss paritaire puisqu'on a
entendu les chefs de fil de la majorité
sénatoriale de droite et du centre
appelé à voter pour ses conclusions de
la CMP elle a droité le centre qui se
revendique de beaucoup des mesures qui
sont restées dans le texte final des
députés et sénateurs et qui sont donc
les conclusions que sont en train de
voter en ce moment le Sénat le plus
simple sera fait à ce moment-là pour
l'exécutif on peut le dire puisque il y
a ensuite à 14h à 15h cet après-midi les
conclusions de cette même CMP qui
arriveront à l'Assemblée nationale ou là
et bien on verra s'il y aura le
déclenchement de l'article 49-3 ou si
une majorité se dessinera pour voter les
conclusions de cette commission mix
paritaire alors que ce scrutin public
est toujours en cours et que donc les
sénateurs votent avec leur carte
électronique dans l'hémicycle on va
avoir comme ça la cartographie de
l'ensemble du vote avec et bien tous les
sénateurs les 344 votants qu'on avait vu
samedi dernier on a je vous rappelle ce
scrutin de samedi dernier sur l'ensemble
de la réforme des retraites avec le vote
unique on avait eu 195 pour 112 contre
on verra si c'est le même vote qui se
joue dans les prochaines secondes un
vote qui est donc en cours que vous
suivez en direct sur notre antenne ça va
voilà se conclure maintenant et on va
aller suivre le résultat de ce scrutin
dans l'hémicycle puisque effectivement
les huissiers sont en train de clôturer
le va ton écoute le résultat de ce
scrutin
le scrutin est clos
résultat du scrutin
votant 345
exprimés 307 pour 193
contre 114 de Sénat à adopter
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente
oui pour préciser à mes collègues de la
commission des affaires sociales une
réunion en salle 216 car nous avons un
amendement sur la PPL wattemblade que
nous devons examiner tout à l'heure il
n'y avait pas d'amendement jusqu'ici
donc nous avions annulé la commission
mais il y a un amendement du
Gouvernement donc réunion salle 216 je
vais mes chers collègues
suspendre la séance ce quelques instants
pour permettre à chacun
s'installer pour l'examen du prochain
point l'ordre du jour la séance est
suspendue pour 5 minutes
voilà vous venez de le vivre en direct
sur l'antenne de Public Sénat la
première étape de cette lecture des
conclusions de la commission esparitaire
qui est franchie pour l'exécutif puisque
le Sénat vient d'adopter ses conclusions
de la commission Miss paritaire vous le
voyez grâce à notre aviateur Philippe de
Sony voici le scrutin qui vient d'avoir
lieu pour 193 contre 114 le Sénat a
adopté cette conclusion de la commission
mix paritaire par rapport au scrutin sur
l'ensemble de la réforme des retraites
c'est de voir en moins dans le vote pour
et de voir en plus dans le vote contre
par rapport à ce qui s'était joué samedi
dernier pour en parler on va rejoindre
notre journaliste parlementaire Mathias
Arès Mathias vous m'accompagnez depuis
9h ce matin racontez-nous comment ça
s'est passé aujourd'hui ben écoutez
Quentin on pensait que ce serait une
formalité au final il aura fallu presque
deux heures ici au Sénat pour finalement
adopter les conclusions de cette
commission mixte paritaire qui s'est
tenue hier toute la journée à
l'Assemblée alors pour vous résumer à
nouveau les débats le protocole veut
de cette discussion générale et bien les
rapporteurs du Sénat pour cette
commission mixte pariétaire ont pris la
parole donc René Paul Savary et
Elizabeth Doisneau ont donc exposé les
conclusions de cette CMP avant que le
gouvernement s'épanche en longueur
également sur cette CMP pour résumer un
petit peu finalement tous les débats qui
ont eu lieu ici dans l'hémicycle du
Sénat avant que finalement et bien on
pensait qu'on allait passer aux
explications de vote mais le
gouvernement a décidé de ce moment pour
imposer un nouvel amendement à l'article
6 annexe un amendement technique qui
venait donc rééquilibrer les comptes de
cette réforme suite aux aménagements de
la CMP une un amendement qui a donc créé
un petit peu de trouble ici dans
l'hémicycle puisqu'il a provoqué une
suspension d'un peu plus de 15 minutes
le temps que la commission des affaires
sociales se réunissent pour rééchanger
sur cette amendement donc nous sommes
ensuite passés aux explications de votre
pendant un peu moins d'une heure où on a
vu renaître les tensions qui étaient
présentes ici pendant les débats pendant
les 10 jours de débat sur cette réforme
des retraites avant de finalement passer
au vote et les résultats que vous venez
donc d'annoncer Quentin merci Mathias et
donc c'est l'information de cette
matinée le Sénat qui adopte les
conclusions de la commission mix
paritaire qui était réunie hier à
l'Assemblée nationale pour en parler
j'accueil ici Guillaume gontin bonjour
bonjour monsieur gontin merci de m'avoir
rejoint sur le public Sénat qui est
installé en salle les conférences une
réaction la première donc à notre micro
sur ce vote par la droite et le centre
d'abord on sait que c'est pas une
surprise puisque on savait évidemment
que que ce texte révolté ici au Sénat
par contre il y a quand même une petite
surprise
vote sur l'article sur l'article 7 je
crois que c'était 201 votant pour
ensuite on est passé à 195 sur
l'ensemble du texte on est en 193 donc
on voit bien qu'on a vraiment une
majorité qui s'est rôle qui s'effrite à
mesure des débats que les parlementaires
les sénatrices les sénateurs
s'aperçoivent que cette réforme elle est
très difficile à défendre sur le terrain
et que petit à petit ben on perd des
voix et je pense que c'est de bonne
augure sur ce qui se passera à
ressembler national parce que je pense
pas qu'il y ait de majorité justement
l'Assemblée en tout cas je ne l'espère
pas et si le gouvernement est obligé de
passer par le 49-3 évidemment ça sera un
aveu d'échec parce que nous utilisez le
49-3 ça voudra dire nous n'avons pas de
majorité donc nous le dites vous voyez
dans la dynamique des votes au fur et à
mesure de l'examen de la réforme des
retraites avec cette dernière étape
aujourd'hui quelque chose qui dénote
d'un doute c'est les droits chez la dans
la droite chez les républicains on voit
bien et on le voit bien quand on quand
on discute avec avec nos collègues il y
a un doute on voit bien que que cette
réforme et on l'a vu d'ailleurs dans ce
qui s'est passé dans ce qui s'est passé
ce matin avec cet amendement de cette
page qui nous est même pas distribué
gouvernement et une méthode qui ne va
pas du tout et qui connaît l'ensemble
oui mais qui reflète tout le travail
autour de ce de ce texte d'approximation
de bricolage d'ajout d'approximation
totale qui n'est franchement pas à la
hauteur de de ce qu'on pourrait attendre
sur un texte qui va engager quand même
la vie des Français pendant de plusieurs
décennies on a entendu à ce micro depuis
le matin des parlementaires du groupe
communiste et socialiste dire qu'il y
avait un avant après dans la niveau de
tension entre la droite et la gauche
sénatoriale on l'a encore vu en séance
ce matin vous le dites aussi c'est un
niveau d'énervement qui continue à être
très problématique
c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné on
peut pas comme ça nier passer par-dessus
par dessus les oppositions et et la
méthode qui ont été utilisées à la fois
par les différents dispositifs pour
censurer le Parlement et la parole de
l'opposition oui forcément ça crée ça
crée des tensions donc oui oui on sent
ces temps surmonter mais elle recommence
dans le pays qui sont particulièrement
inquiétantes parce que les Françaises et
les Français ne se sentent pas du tout
écouter j'ai une dernière question vous
le dites le gouvernement va passer par
49-3 vous en êtes certains vous ah je
suis pas certain en tout cas ce que je
sais c'est que cette c'est cette
tentative du président Macron d'essayer
de trouver une une majorité on le voit
bien ce matin ce matin à l'Élysée c'est
ce à tenté de tenter de faire si
l'utilisa l'utilisation une nouvelle
réunion même à midi
la majorité présidentielle du 49-3 et
c'est ce qu'on est en train d'entendre
ça sera un terrible terrible aveu
d'échec ça voudra juste dire nous
n'avons pas la majorité et donc on est
encore une fois obligé de passer en
force donc je pense que derrière il n'y
aura plus que le retrait sinon ça sera
très grave oui et qu'est-ce que ça te
dirait effectivement de est-ce qu'il se
joue politiquement sur l'échiquier il
faudrait une dissolution ensuite en tout
cas là c'est une très lourde
responsabilité du gouvernement si le
gouvernement veut passer comme ça en
force forcément de toute façon il y aura
une émotion de censure et évidemment
j'espère qu'elle sera votée puisqu'il
nous restera plus que ça merci Guillaume
Gontard d'être venu à notre micro je
vais accueillir Patrick canner le chef
de fil des socialistes qui va
s'installer à votre place et qui va
pouvoir nous donner son sentiment sur ce
vote puisque vous l'avez vécu sur notre
antenne 193 pour 114 contre le Sénat
adopté les conclusions de la commission
mix paritaire bonjour Patrick canonjo
président du groupe socialiste au Sénat
une réaction sur ce vote écoutez deux
voix de moi encore pour la majorité ils
étaient à 195 ils sont aujourd'hui à 183
bon c'est pas c'est pas majeur mais
c'est pas inintéressant ça montre que le
texte n'est vraiment pas totalement
consensuel c'est moi qu'on puisse dire
au sein de la majorité c'est la toriale
donc c'est à suivre on va analyser le
vote des uns et les autres c'est
intéressant donc on aura le détail
exactement de ce que chaque sénateur a
pu faire dans l'hémicycle au moment du
vote et donc si on verra qui est-ce qui
c'est effectivement qui a changé de vote
entre samedi dernier et maintenant ça
c'est au moins l'intérêt du flou de un
public c'est qu'on sait qui vote quoi ça
il y a aussi le fait de ralentir les
débats pour la gauche natale peut-être
en tout cas nous nous on va regarder de
très près maintenant ce qui va se passer
à l'Assemblée parce que si un 49-3 là on
ne sait pas ce qui se passe on ne sait
pas qui vote quoi c'était ma question
est-ce que vous voyez dans cette
évolution du vote au fur et à mesure de
la réforme des retraites une fébrilité
de la part DLR qui dénoterait ce qui va
se jouer et qui permettrait de
comprendre ce qui va se jouer cet
après-midi je ne suis pas membre de
l'exécutif mais ce vote ce matin au
Sénat que certains auraient pu espérer
plus large en faveur de la réforme ce
n'est pas le cas donc ça peut
interpeller effectivement le président
Macron parce que ça montre tout
simplement que il y a des LR qui ne
veulent pas mettre leur nom sur cette
réforme le présent République inqui qui
réunit les dirigeants de la majorité
présidentielle à midi à l'Elysée après
l'avoir fait ce matin à 8h15 qu'est-ce
que ça dit là encore que c'est bien vers
elle se déclenchement de 49-3 c'est vers
cela qu'on va c'est une fébrilité de la
part de l'exécutif moi je ne suis pas
dans l'exécutif naturellement mais
réunir les dirigeants un peu en
catastrophe ce n'est pas prévu
initialement ça veut dire très
simplement très simplement que
aujourd'hui Emmanuel Macron doute encore
sa capacité à pouvoir faire passer par
les voies normales ce texte donc encore
une fois il y a sur lequel il y a une
opposition majeure dans le pays donc on
se retrouve devant un exécutif qui est
dos au mur dans les cordes et un petit
peu sonné je le pense s'il y a un 49-3
cet après-midi Patrick canner qu'est-ce
que vous appelez à faire qu'est-ce que
le gouvernement doit faire le 49-3 est
consécutionnel dont acte la gauche tu as
utilisé mais avoir adopter le texte au
Sénat avec un 44 3 votre bloqué un 49-3
le grand vote bloqué ça pose un vrai
problème ça pose un vrai problème sur
une réforme qui touche quand même des
millions de nos concitoyens je le dis
Manuel Valls vous l'avez dit à utiliser
49-3 mais là on touche à la vie à la vie
des gens dans ce pays et c'est quand
même très différent si un 49-3 ça
signifie dépôt d'une motion par la
gauche qu'est-ce qui va se passer encore
une fois il y aura d'émotions séparées
différents groupes la gauche va déposer
une motion oui bien sûr si un 49-3
d'ailleurs même 149 francs on pourrait
déposer une motion c'est tout ça fait
possible mais je tiens à dire que jamais
jamais il n'y aura de signature commune
d'une motion avec l'extrême droite et
qu'elle doit être l'étape d'après c'est
ma dernière question est-ce qu'on peut
imaginer une dissolution dans les
prochaines semaines
là vous me posez des questions qu'il
faut c'est un peu le mouvement
c'est l'arme lourde c'est le chantage
permanent aujourd'hui vis-à-vis des
députés moi ce que je sais c'est ce que
nous allons faire et il est fort
probable que nous ayons l'envie de
demander au peuple ce prononcer au
travers peut-être d'un référendum
d'initiative partagée et bien sur
référendum d'initiative partagée ou RIP
que la gauche va déposer les trois
groupes de gauche vous allez déposer
comme on l'avait vu sur Aéroport de
Paris et ça avait marché et ça avait
fonctionné alors il y avait eu le covid
aussi qui avait peut-être compliqué la
donne pour pour l'exécutif merci Patrick
Kanner de cette de cette réaction
microculture nous on va rejoindre notre
journaliste Mathias arez en tribune de
presse Mathias racontez-nous ce qui
s'est joué aujourd'hui bah écoutez quand
on a vu renaître le temps d'une
explication de votre clivages gauche
droite un petit peu un remake un replay
de ce qu'on avait vécu pendant 10 jours
ici pendant l'hémicycle leur des débats
donc chaque président de groupe ou chef
de fil pour la question des retraites a
donc pris la parole pendant 5 minutes
pour expliquer son vote pour les
républicains c'est la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales
Catherine Deroche qui n'a pas parlé de
pacte avec le gouvernement mais de
responsabilité je vous propose de
l'écouter
c'est pourquoi le groupe les
républicains invite le Sénat voter ce
texte et apprendre ses responsabilités
avec courage comme il l'a fait de
manière constante nous sommes conscients
que ce texte marque une étape et qu'il
doit s'accompagner de changement
profonds dans la prise en compte des
salariés les plus âgés dans une économie
en pénurie de main d'oeuvre il est
évident qu'ils ont toutes leurs places
ce chantier avant tout celui des
entreprises et des partenaires sociaux
avant d'être celui de la loi néanmoins
ces deux changements législatifs
s'avèrent nécessaire nous répondrons
près sur la santé travail sur
l'assurance chômage et sur toutes les
réformes affectant le fonctionnement du
marché du travail la retraite ne
s'arrête le seul horizon pour les jeunes
qui ont dit cela toute leur vie à
construire pour les explications venues
de la gauche on a donc entendu Monique
Lubin et Cathy a pourso poli être à
l'offensive une offensive jusqu'à la
dernière minute en attaquant notamment
l'irrégularité des débats Tim Mathias
pour toutes ces explications c'est
l'information de cette matinée au Sénat
le Sénat qui adopte les conclusions de
la commission mix paritaire 193 voies
pour 114 contre pour en parler j'ai
accueilli Bruno retaillod bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le président du groupe
les républicains le premier groupe a en
importance ici au Sénat un mot sur cette
dernière étape a priori dans l'examen de
la réforme et le Sénat qui adopte cette
conclusion de la commission Miss
paritaire pardon d'abord le Sénat adopté
cette réforme qui est importante cette
réforme elle est là pour sauver le
régime de retraite par compétition s'il
explose sous le poids des déficits ce
serait les plus fragiles qui pourraient
trinquer les plus modestes et la bonne
nouvelle c'est que il n'y aura pas de
baisse de pension pas de baisse des
retraites et que les jeunes n'auront pas
à payer de retraite la note si j'ose
dire et puis et puis la leur pas plus
non plus de notamment d'augmentation
d'impôts le Sénat qui adopte ses
conclusions parce que c'est ce qu'on a
entendu dans les prises de parole
notamment de René Paul Savary le texte
final le la CMP était globalement le
texte de la droite et du centre du Sénat
c'est bien ça je pense que depuis le
départ on a imprimé une marque très très
forte au Sénat puisque tous les ans nous
votion cette amendement et
l'architecture de la réforme c'est à
dire 43 annuités et accélération voilà
64 ans viennent d'ici mais surtout on a
enrichi l'hôtel on l'a enrichi pour les
maires de famille on l'a enrichi aussi
pour légionnaire les femmes qui ont eu
un enfant on l'a enrichi pour tous ces
seniors qui sont au chômage et qu'on
veut les tirer du chômage pour les
remettre en emploi à travers un contrat
durée terminé justement finit après
négociation avec les partenaires la
fraude aussi qui va rapporter quand même
en 2030 qui va rapporter 200 millions
d'euros si on demande des efforts aux
Français on doit aussi sanctionner plus
sévèrement la fraude est-ce que c'est
normal qu'aujourd'hui il y a à
l'étranger des gens qui sont pourtant
décédés et des retraites de ces gens-là
décédés qui sont pour autant perçus
Bruno otao dans ce contexte comment
comprendre que ce texte que vous avez
largement amendé et bien il fasse débat
au sein de vos députés on attend de
savoir cet après-midi si ils vont voter
ou pas à la réforme et bien presque 20
d'entre eux disent déjà qu'ils vont
voter contre comment comprendre ce vote
personnellement je le comprends parce
que il y a sans doute des fortes
pressions dans les circonscriptions et
je ne le comprends pas d'un point de vue
politique qu'est-ce qui fait l'honneur
de la politique c'est la constance c'est
une ligne politique comment comprendre
que alors que depuis des années et des
mois encore ont soutenait une réforme
qui portait à 65 ans
on vous a entendu lors de l'examen de
ces conclusions de la commission mix
paritaire car vous étiez le chef de fil
des centristes sur la réforme des
retraites un mot 193 voie pour c'est un
peu moins que sur l'ensemble du texte
samedi dernier c'est de voir de moins
avec le vote d'aujourd'hui par rapport à
l'ensemble de la réforme des retraites
comment ça s'explique quelques-uns ont
changé leur vote dans votre camp non je
crois pas parce que on a eu des
changements même favorables mais enfin
faut regarder ça de près mais
l'essentiel c'est qu'il ait été voté et
qu'on assure la pérennité du système de
retraite par répartition je vais vous
dire c'est ça qu'on va retenir dans les
dans les semaines qui viennent le
système par répartition survie et les
retraites sont garanties l'étape d'après
c'est l'Assemblée nationale alors ça
vous êtes certes vous êtes sénateur vous
n'avez pas vocation à commenter ce qui
se passe dans la chambre l'autre chambre
du Parlement mais tout de même qu'est-ce
que ça dit une droite qui vote un texte
au Sénat et qui ne le vote pas ensuite à
l'Assemblée nationale puisque c'est le
cas pour une dizaine peut-être une
vingtaine de députés LR moi j'ai une
doctrine je ne parle jamais des autres
je parle de de mon groupe et de moi-même
et je vais vous dire il y a une étape
d'après pour nous c'est la conférence
sociale et la réhabilitation et la
rénovation du paritarisme et du dialogue
social voilà notre cap en suivant ça
merci pour cette réaction une école
publique c'est à vous de nous avoir
suivis merci aux équipes techniques
éditoriales qui ont encore une fois
permis ce Grand Direct prochaine étape à
l'Assemblée nationale le vote est à 15